ओके सो वी आर गोइंग लाइव आई
थिंक आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
नाउ ओके चलिए तो लाइव हम आ चुके हैं प्लीज
लेट मी नो गाइस इफ आई एम ऑडिबल विजिबल
क्लियर सब कुछ सब कुछ बढ़िया है एक बार
बता दीजिए आप लोग सभी लोग बता दीजिए एंड
सभी को आ जाने देते हैं एक बार जवाइन हो
जाने देते हैं तो जल्दी से बता दीजिए
फटाफट
बताइए ओके सो आईम गुड आई एम गुड हेलो हेलो
आई एम
गुड इट्स बैड यू प्रॉमिस दैट नेक्स्ट
वीडियो प्रिविलेज एलेशन प आएंगी क्लासेस
टेंशन नहीं लेनी है उसके पहले कुछ जरूरी
चीजें हैं वह आप कर लीजिए पहले सब बढ़िया
ओके ठीक है तो सभी को आ जाने देते हैं
पहले एक बार सभी लोगों को यहां पर जवाइन
करने देते हैं पहले देन स्टार्ट करेंगे
लेट एवरी बडी
कम चलिए 31 पीपल हैव जॉइड बाकी लोगों को
भी आ जाने देते हैं देन ओनली वी विल
स्टार्ट इज डीएसए रिक्वायर्ड इन इंटरव्यूज
हां डीएसए की रिक्वायरमेंट तो होती है भाई
डीएसए की इंपॉर्टेंस है मतलब आपको नॉलेज
होनी चाहिए डीएसए की इफ यू हैव नॉलेज देन
इट विल बी गुड ठीक है मैं यहां
पे मॉनिटरिंग कर लेता हूं दूसरे अपने
डिवाइस पे लेट मी स्टार्ट वेर इट इज वेर
इट इज कहां गई भैया हां जी आ गई चलिए तो
यहां पे
डन हां जी 43 पीपल हैव जॉइन टिल
नाउ बाकी लोग कहां गए बाकी लोग कहां गए
भैया जल्दी आ जाओ यार जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी
जल्दी तो काफी टाइम बाद हम मिल रहे हैं
फाइनली आफ्टर लॉन्ग लंग लंग गैप काफी लंबा
गैप हो गया है उसके लिए एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी
आप सबको एंड इस गैप का रीजन जो है मैं
आपको ऑलरेडी बता चुका हूं ठीक है ऑलरेडी
आप सबको रीजन शॉर्ट्स के थ्रू बता चुका
हूं कि क्या रीजन था इस गैप का एंड आप
सबको जिनको नहीं पता मैं वापस से रिपीट कर
देता हूं कि मैं डे फ्रक्स के कुछ बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट काम में बिजी था काफी दिनों से
एंड अभी भी बिजी हूं एंड आगे कुछ टाइम तक
और बिजी होने वाला हूं तो डेनिक्स को
ऑफलाइन लेकर आने वाले हैं एंड बेसिकली यू
कैन से वी आर गोइंग कंपलीटली ऑफलाइन आल्सो
इन ऑनलाइन जो चीजें चल रही है ऑपरेट हो
रही है हमारी जो ऑपरेशंस है प्रोसेसेस है
सब चलेंगे जैसे चल रहा है बट हम ऑफलाइन भी
जाने वाले हैं डेल्ली एनसीआर से स्टार्ट
करने वाले हैं एंड स्लोली स्लोली वीी विल
बी स्प्रेडिंग अप इन द इंडिया तो ये एक
छोटा सा हमारा एक स्टेप अप है आप बोल सकते
हैं हमारे एक स्टार्टअप का हमारी कंपनी का
लाइक वी आर टेकिंग अ स्टेप अहेड एंड बहुत
जल्द आपको एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन आपको सारी
डिटेल्स कंपनी कहां पे आपकी कंपनी हमारी
जो है कहां पे हमारी कंपनी अ का हेड ऑफिस
कहां पे एस्टेब्लिश हुआ है कहां पे सारी
चीजें आपको प्रोवाइड की जाएंगी एंड एक
छोटा सा इनॉग्रल इवेंट भी होगा जहां आप
सबको इनवाइट किया जाएगा एंड आप सबको वहां
पे आना है जो भी आ सकते हैं जो भी जिनके
पास भी टाइम हो सकता है पॉसिबिलिटी है वो
जरूर आइएगा एंड एंड वी विल हैव अ ग्रेट
ग्रेट सम ऑफर्स एंड ऑल बहुत शानदार चीजें
होने वाली है तो अभी सबका वेट कीजिए एंड
देन वो टाइम भी बहुत जल्द आने वाला है ठीक
है
या प्लीज डोंट स्पैम इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट टू
एवरीबॉडी तो बहुत कुछ होने वाला है अभी
ऑफलाइन में आपको अभी आप आपके इमेजिनेशन के
बाहर की चीजें भी होने वाली है एंड ऑफर हम
इतनी बढ़िया चीजें देने वाले प्रोवाइड
करने वाले हैं ऑन आवर फर्स्ट बैच इन
ऑफलाइन कि आप यकीन नहीं करेंगे शायद उस
टाइम पे तो चलिए कोई बात नहीं वी विल बी अ
वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग सेशन एंड काफी दिनों
के बाद मिले हैं तो आई होप आप सब ठीक
होंगे सब अच्छे होंगे बढ़िया होंगे हेल्दी
होंगे एंड कीप स्माइलिंग एवरीबॉडी हंसते
रहिए एंड मजे में रहिए ठीक है लाइफ छोटी
है
चलिए या ओके सो नाउ आई होप कि आप सबको
क्लियर विजिबल एंड क्लियर ऑडिबल है सब कुछ
तो यहां पे स्टार्ट करते हैं स्टार्ट करने
से सॉरी स्टार्ट करने से पहले यहां पे
सिंपल बता देता हूं ये डेनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का हमारा लिंकन पेज है इसको
फॉलो करके रखिएगा सारी कंपनी की अपडेट
डिटेल्स एंड जो भी हमारी अपकमिंग
नोटिफिकेशंस होंगे कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग
आपको यहां पे सब कुछ दिख जाएगा 13000
लोगों ने ऑलरेडी फॉलो कर रखा है आप भी
इनमें से बन जाइए एंड हमारी स्टार्टअप
जर्नी के साथ जुड़े रहिए एंड हमारे
स्टार्टअप जर्नी को एंजॉय कीजिए ये हमारा
डेनिक्स का
instagram2 अपडेट्स प्लेस स्टूडेंट्स एंड
बहुत सारी चीजें यहां पे आपको मिल जाएंगी
जो भी इवेंट्स वगैरह होते हैं उसकी
डिटेल्स भी मिल जाएंगी तो प्लीज कम एंड
फॉलो दिस आल्सो ये हमारी वेबसाइट है इससे
अपडेटेड रहेंगे और ये हमारा कांटेक्ट नंबर
है अगर आपको कोई भी क्वेरीज हो
साथ ही में हमारे एक
whatsapp.apk पे आके चैनल को फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा ठीक है चलिए और आप सबको पता ही
होगा हमने रिसेंट लिए एक वीए पीटी की बहुत
ही शानदार जॉब ओरिएंटेड ट्रेनिंग लॉन्च की
थी जिसकी कि ट्रेनिंग की प्री बुकिंग
वगैरह सब कुछ क्लोज हो गई है हो गई है
यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं रजिस्ट्रेशंस आर
नाउ क्लोज्ड तो अगर आपको नेक्स्ट बैच में
आना है तो आप नेक्स्ट बैच में आ सकते हैं
अप्रैल 2025 में नेक्स्ट बैच आएगी एंड ये
बैच सिक्स मंथ्स की चलेगी एंड फर्दन
इंक्वायरी के लिए आप हमारे नंबर पे
तरीके से आज आपके सामने आया हूं एंड कुछ
डिफरेंट चीजों को आपको बताने वाला हूं एंड
कुछ अलग तरीके से हम काम करने वाले हैं सो
नाउ वी आर गोइंग मोर अ इंडस्ट्री अ मोर
इंडस्ट्री अ लेवल की तरह जैसे कि हम
इंडस्ट्री में जिस तरीके से काम होती है
जिस तरीके से हम इंडस्ट्री में लोग काम
करते हैं ना एंड जो जो टूल्स पे काम कर
रहे हैं जो तरीके आजमा रहे हैं जिस तरीके
से अ वीपीटी के प्रोजेक्ट्स को हैंडल करते
हैं या या वेब एप्लीकेशन पेन टेस्टिंग के
प्रोजेक्ट को हैंडल किया जाता है जिन
टूल्स का यूज़ किया जाता है जो मेथड जो
तरीके यूज़ किए जाते हैं हम उनसे
थोड़ा-थोड़ा अलाइन होना शुरू करेंगे
क्योंकि बिगनर लेवल की यानी कि बेसिक लेवल
की जो आपकी बग बाउंट की ये प्लेलिस्ट है
वो ऑलरेडी काफी कुछ हमने कवर कर लिया है
अब टाइम है थोड़ा सा स्टेप अप लेने का
थोड़ा सा स्टेप अप करने का एंड थोड़ा सा
एडवांस जाने का एंड थोड़ा एडवांस मैं
इसलिए बोल रहा हूं बिकॉज़ ये अभी भी
कंप्लीट एडवांस नहीं है बहुत कुछ अभी बचा
हुआ है हम धीरे-धीरे कवर करते चलेंगे एंड
बहुत ही आगे एडवांस तक भी जाएंगे याद
रखिएगा बग बाउंट की ये सीरीज काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट है आप सबसे रिक्वेस्ट है कि
प्लीज प्लीज आप सब जरूर इस सीरीज को फॉलो
कीजिए एंड अगर हो सके तो सारी वीडियोस
कलीग्स हैं जो बैचमेट्स हैं जिनको बक
बाउंट में इंटरेस्ट है सो न्यूक्लि आई टूल
के ऊपर हम बात करने वाले हैं न्यूक्लि आई
टूल ठीक है यह एक सिंपल सिंपल लैंग्वेज
में समझे तो ऑटोमेटेड स्कैनर है और कुछ भी
नहीं है ठीक है ऑटोमेटेड
स्कैनर ऑटोमेटेड स्कैनर अ हाईली
कस्टमाइजेबल
हाईली कस्टमाइजेबल ठीक है ये एक ऐसा टूल
है जो एक ऑटोमेटेड स्कैनर के साथ-साथ एक
हाईली कस्टमाइजेबल टूल है अब मैं हाईली
कस्टमाइजेबल टूल के और ओपन सोर्स भी है
आपका तो आपको यहां पे कोई टेंशन नहीं लेनी
है बिंदास आपको इसको यूज़ करना है अब
न्यूक्लि टूल एक ऑटोमेटेड स्कैनर के
साथ-साथ हाईली कस्टमाइजेबल है यानी कि आप
इसको जिस तरीके से चाहें उस तरीके से यूज
कर सकते हैं अपने अकॉर्डिंग इसको कंफिल कर
सकते हैं चेंजेज कर सकते हैं अपने
अकॉर्डिंग आप इसमें डिफरेंट डिफरेंट काइंड
ऑफ चीजें जो है ऐड ऑन कर सकते हैं खुद के
टेंपलेट्स बना सकते हैं क्योंकि लिई टूल
जो है दिस टूल दिस टूल वर्क ऑन टेंपलेट्स
टेंपलेट्स पे बेसिकली ये काम करता है
टेंपलेट्स मेनली मैं लिख देता हूं बिकॉज़
सिर्फ टेंपलेट्स की बात नहीं है यहां पे
बट यहां पे मैं मेनली लिख देता हूं ठीक है
अब ये जो टेंपलेट्स है ना टेंपलेट्स आपके
जो बने होते हैं ये बन ये इसमें यूज़ होता
है वाई एमएल ठीक है वाई एएमएल ठीक है ये
एक तरह का मार्कअप आप बोल सकते हैं
लैंग्वेज एक तरह का बोल सकते हैं जिसपे कि
ये काम करता है एंड ये काफी इजी टू यूज
होता है काफी इजी आप इसको सीख सकते हैं और
खुद के न्यूक्लि टेंप्लेट भी बना सकते हैं
अगर आपकी डिमांड होगी या अगर आप चाहेंगे
तो हम एक और और सेशन में थोड़े एडवांस की
तरफ जाते हुए न्यूक्लि के टेंपलेट्स
क्रिएट करना भी सीख लेंगे तो लेट मी नो इन
द चैट इफ यू वांट दैट पर्टिकुलर वीडियो तो
मैं इस सेशन के बाद एक और सेशन लेके हम उस
पे भी काम कर लेंगे कि न्यूक्लि से
ऑटोमेशन एंड खुद के टेंपलेट्स अगर आपको
क्रिएट करने हैं किसी भी तरह की लेबिलिटी
को फाइंड करने के लिए तो आप कैसे वो
क्रिएट कर सकते हैं तो अगर आपकी डिमांड
होगी तो ओबवियसली वो चीज आ जाएगी तो इफ यू
वांट दैट राइट अभी फिलहाल तो हम ऑलरेडी
मेड टेंपलेट्स को समझेंगे न्यूक्लि को
समझेंगे न्यूक्लि के वर्किंग को समझ
न्यूक्लिया किस तरीके से इंटरेक्ट करती है
होस्ट से उसको समझेंगे हर एक चीज समझेंगे
एंड देन हम उस पर आ जाएंगे तो
यस ओके
ओके ओके ग्रेट ठीक है अभी मैं किसी के
इंक्वारीज या क्वेरीज कोई ज्यादा नहीं ले
रहा मैं अभी फोकस क्लास पे कर रहा हूं तो
चैट को मैं ज्यादा अभी कंसीडर नहीं कर रहा
ध्यान नहीं दे रहा तो अगर आपके कोई
क्वेश्चंस है तो प्लीज हम एंड में उसको
देखेंगे ठीक है तो एंड तक आप जुड़े रहिएगा
चलिए तो यहां पे वाईएमएल बनती है अब इसकी
थोड़ी डिटेल देखो कोई भी टूल ना यू यूज
करना वैसे तो आसान होता है काफी इजी होता
है कोई भी टूल को यूज कर लेना बहुत इजी है
कोई भी यूज कर लेगा बट उस टूल को समझना
उसका बैकग्राउंड कंसेप्ट समझना बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट होता है अगर आप बिना
उसके समझे उस टूल को डायरेक्टली यूज करना
शुरू कर देते हैं तो आप बहुत कुछ मिस
करेंगे एंड बहुत सारी जो फंक्शनैलिटी उस
टूल के तरफ से ऑफर की जाती है वो आप शायद
पूरा यूज ना कर पाए या पूरी मतलब अच्छे
तरीके से उसको यूज ना कर पाए एंड बहुत
सारी चीजों आप चीजों को आप मिस कर जाए कर
दें ठीक है उस टूल की तो चलिए तो यहां पे
इस टूल का नाम है है न्यूक्लि आई एंड इसका
जो रिपोजिटरी है गिट हब के ऊपर आपको यहां
पे मिल जाएगा प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी के अंदर
में न्यूक्लि आई ठीक है आप सिंपल
google3 है इसको इंस्टॉल करने का बहुत
सिंपल तरीका है काली के रिपोजिटरी में
ऑलरेडी ये डेड है अगर आपको मैं काली
लिनिक्स गो टू द काली मशीन हियर मैं यहां
पे टर्मिनल एक ओपन कर लेता हूं एंड इसको
थोड़ा सा जूम आउट कर लेता हूं मैं ठीक
है हम हम हां तो अगर मैं देखूं यहां पे
एप्ट लिस्ट एंड न्यूक्लि आई तो आपको
दिखेगा कि न्यूक्लि आई ऑलरेडी काली
रिपोजिटरी में डेड है काली रोलिंग में एंड
आप यहां पे हमारा इंस्टॉल्ड है तो आपको
अगर इंस्टॉल करना है नहीं इंस्टॉल है तो
बहुत सिंपल सा तरीका है आपको क्या करना है
पप गेट इंस्टॉल पप गेट इंस्टॉल एंड
न्यूक्लि आई करना है एंड एंटर कर देना है
एंड आपका न्यूक्लि जो है वो इंस्टॉल होके
आ जाएगा ठीक है जब पहली बार आप न्य को लॉच
करेंगे सिंपली न्यूक्लि लिख के भी एंटर कर
देंगे तो यह जो टेंपलेट्स है इसके जो
डिफॉल्ट टेंपलेट्स है उसको इंस्टॉल कर
देगा एंड उसकी एक लोकेशन है वहां पे वो
लोकेशन पे ये टेंपलेट्स को रख देगा ठीक है
दैट्ची किया यहां पे आ रहा है करंट
न्यूक्लि वर्जन 3.3.2 लेटेस्ट वर्जन है
करंट न्यूक्लि टेंप्लेट वर्जन जो है 10 है
लेटेस्ट है यहां पे बाकी स्कैन रिजल्ट्स
यह जो है यह सब कुछ चीजें आपको नहीं मिल
रही है बिकॉज हमने कोई भी होस्ट यहां पे
स्पेसिफाई नहीं करा है
कोई टारगेट हमने स्पेसिफाई नहीं करा है अब
यहां पे न्यू टेंपलेट्स एडेड इन लेटेस्ट
रिलीज हर रिलीज में ना न्यूक्लि के अंदर
कुछ टेंप्लेट ऐड किए जाते हैं जब भी
न्यूक्लि की नई रिलीज होती है उसमें कुछ
न्यू टेंपलेट्स ऐड किए जाते हैं तो वो
टेंपलेट्स दिखा रहा है कि 255 टेंपलेट्स
को नए ऐड किए गए हैं और टोटल टेंपलेट्स
लगभग जो इस करंट स्कैन के लिए लोड किया
गया है वो 8506 टेंपलेट्स है यानी बहुत
सारे टेंपलेट्स ऑलरेडी यहां पे है ठीक है
आप देख सकते हैं 8505 टेंपलेट्स को जो है
साइंड टेंपलेट्स को यहां पे ये एग्जीक्यूट
करेगा एंड वन अनसाइंड अनसाइंड टेंपलेट्स
है उसको भी यहां पे स्कैन अ स्कैन के लिए
यहां पे यूज कर रहा है तो ये बोल रहा है
यूज विद कॉशन तो मतलब कॉशन के साथ यूज
कीजिए क्योंकि अनसाइंड है
दैट्ची डियर इट्स अ ग्रेट थिंग चलो
बहुत-बहुत बढ़िया आपने इतने दिनों बाद भी
अपनी एनर्जी को अपनी डेडिकेशन को बजा बना
के रखा है सच बताओ मुझे सच बताओ आप में से
कितने लोग क्लास को मिस कर रहे थे एकदम
लिटरली ईमानदारी से बताना ऐसा नहीं वो वो
वाली मत करना यार कि मतलब अ एक होता है ना
मुह मिया मिट्ठू वो वाली काम मत करना कि
मुंह पे मुंह पे बोल देना है भाई अच्छे से
अच्छे अच्छा बोलो सर को बढ़िया लगेगा सर
को कितने लोग एक्चुअली मिस कर रहे थे
क्लास को मतलब मिस कर रहे होंगे तभी बताना
नहीं कर रहे तो कोई बात नहीं है क्योंकि
काफी लोग अभी भी आए 116 लोग आ चुके हैं
115 प्लस लोग यहां जॉइन कर चुके हैं इसका
मतलब है आपके अंदर अभी भी वो वो जो है ना
चिनगारी वो अभी भी बची हुई है अभी भी आपके
अंदर की वो चीज खत्म हुई नहीं है वीपीटी
को या बग बाउंटीज को लेके
मेनली ओके काफी लोगों ने काफी लोग मिस कर
रहे थे एंड एक्चुअली आई आल्सो मिस्ड
एवरीबॉडी क्योंकि मैं क्लासेस से जब दूर
होता हूं तो मुझे काफी लाइक अनकंफर्ट बल
फील होता है बट ड्यू टू सम अ अ लाइक
जेनुइन इश्यूज मैं नहीं आ पा रहा था
क्लासेस नहीं ले पा रहा था एंड अभी आपको
आपको दिख भी रहा होगा मेरा लोकेशन भी चेंज
हो चुका है जो मैं पहले जहां से क्लासेस
लेता था एंड अभी जो क्लासेस ले रहा हूं सो
एवरीथिंग इज़ चेंज्ड
ओके सर आई गॉट टोटल $300 बाउंट क्या बात
है अ लिरिकल रशिया कांग्रेचुलेशन ब्रदर
फॉर गेटिंग $300 बाउंटीज
लोगों को भी पता चले आपके बारे में ठीक है
डेट 31 क्या बात है क्या इतने टाइम मिल गए
तो आपको अभी तक तो बहुत सारी क्लासेस
कंप्लीट कर लेनी चाहिए जिनको जिनका पहले
रह गया था पीछे ठीक है तो ये तो हमने
न्यूक्लि को लॉच कर लिया न्यूक्लि को
इंस्टॉल करने के और भी तरीके हैं ठीक है
ऐसा नहीं है कि सिर्फ एक तरीका है और भी
तरीके हैं क्या तरीका है मैं आपको बता
देता हूं यहां पे आप जाएंगे यहां पे आप
देख सकते हैं नीचे की तरफ आएंगे तो
न्यूक्लि आई गो लैंग्वेज अ अगर आपके काली
में गो इंस्टॉल्ड है तो आप डायरेक्टली ये
कमांड चला सकते हैं ये कमांड यहां से कॉपी
करेंगे एंड यहां काली लिनेक्स में जाके
यहां पे सिंपल यहां पे आप क्या करेंगे
पेस्ट कर देंगे गो इंस्टॉल गिट हब ये करके
एंड लिंक दे देंगे आपका न्यूक्लि
इंस्टॉल्ड हो जाएगा बात यह है कि इसके लिए
आपको गो लैंग्वेज इंस्टॉल करना पड़ेगा तो
आप सिंपल पप गेट इंस्टॉल एंड गो लैंग्वेज
कर लीजिएगा इसके पहले पप गेट इंस्टॉल गो
लैंग ये कर लीजिएगा आपका गो इंस्टॉल हो
जाएगा देन आप वो कमांड चला के न्यूक्लि को
वैसे भी इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं अगर आप एक
ये कमांड चला सकते हैं डॉकर के थ्रू आप
इसको रन कर सकते हैं तो ये तो आपको तरीका
बता दिया ठीक है काली में सबसे इजी टू यूज
सबसे इजी टू एग्जीक्यूट आपको कमांड अब
यहां पे न्यूक्लि को हम एक बार पहले रन कर
देते हैं तो न्यूक्लि एंटर करें न्यूक्लि
कमांड देंगे और हाइन एच करेंगे तो इसकी
हेल्प फाइल जो है वो पूरी हेल्प फाइल आपको
सामने आ जाएगी तो यहां पे जैसे ही हमने
हाइन एच किया अब यहां पे इसकी हेल्प फाइल
में बहुत बड़ी सी हेल्प फाइल आ रही है
जैसे एसक्यूएल मैप की हेल्प फाइल आती है
ना लंबी सी एकदम बहुत सारी चीजें होती है
उसके अंदर लोग सोचते हैं अरे यार
क्या-क्या भर रखा है वैसे ही इसकी कुछ
हेल्प फाइल है बट इसकी हेल्प फाइल जो है
वो काफी ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन मतलब आपको
हेल्प फाइल देखना है बस और आपको कुछ नहीं
करना है यार आप पूरी न्यूक्लि को यूज़ कर
सकते हो बेसिकली कस्टम टेंप्लेट से लेके
रिज्यूम करने से लेके रेट लिमिटिंग से
लेके हेडले स मोड से लेके हर एक चीज
टारगेट को डिफाइन करने से लेके हर एक चीज
जो है आप इसके थ्रू कर सकते हैं अब देयर
आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स अब आप न्यूक्लि की
हेल्प फाइल में देखेंगे तो एक तो आपके
पहले फ्लैग्स यहां पे जो जो फ्लैग्स है
टारगेट के रिगार्डिंग तो टारगेट के
रिगार्डिंग जो फ्लैग्स है वो है यहां पे
टारगेट फॉर्मेट है टेंपलेट्स के
रिगार्डिंग यहां पे फ्लैग्स हैं वो है
यहां पे उसके बाद प्राइवेट की उसके बाद
फिल्टरिंग के टैग्स हैं फिल्टरिंग के यहां
पे आपके अ जो टैग्स है वो आपको यहां पे
देखने को मिल जाएंगे फिल्टरिंग से रिलेटेड
जितने भी ऑप्शंस हैं वो सारे मिल जाएंगे
फ्लैग्स आउटपुट से रिलेटेड सारे फ्लैग्स
आपको मिल जाएंगे उसके बाद कॉन्फ़िगरेशन से
रिलेटेड सारे फ्लैग्स आपको मिल जाएंगे
यहां पे बहुत सारे फ्लैग्स यहां पे आपको
देखने को मिलेंगे देन यहां पे इंटरेक्ट
एसेट से रिलेटेड आपको सारे फ्लैग्स जो है
देखने को मिल जाएंगे फजिंग से रिलेटेड स
फ्लैग जो है देखने को मिल जाएंगे अनकवर
मोड एक बेसिकली या अनकवर इंजन बोलिए उससे
रिलेटेड फ्लैग्स आपको देखने को मिल जाएंगे
रेट लिमिटिंग से रिलेटेड एंड ऑप्टिमाइजेशन
से रिलेटेड आपको फ्लैग्स देखने को मिल
जाएंगे फिर हेडले अस मोड एंड डीबगर आता है
उसके रिगार्डिंग भी मिल जाएगा एंड अगर
आपको अपडेट वगैरह करना हो स्टेटिस्टिक्स
वगैरह देखने हैं क्लाउड का यूज करना हो
मतलब बेसिकली क्लाउड के लिए तो वो एंड
ऑथेंटिकेशन ये सारे आपको यहां पे मिल जाते
हैं अब यहां पे अपडेट का ये सिंपल सा फंडा
क्या है कि हान यूटी अब जैसे अपडेट करना
है आपको टेंपलेट्स को तो न्यू आ हान यूटी
कर दीजिए आपका लेटेस्ट वर्जन में अपडेट हो
जाएगा ठीक
है ओके तो हान यटी यूज कर लीजिएगा अगर
आपको मैनुअली अपडेट करनी हो तो न्यूक्लि
के टेंप्लेट को फिलहाल के लिए हमारा सब
कुछ अपडेटेड है तो हमें अभी कुछ नहीं करना
है तो चलिए अब आते हैं यहां पे थोड़ा हम
डिटेल में आज न्यूक्लि को पढ़ेंगे
न्यूक्लि की और भी वीडियो आएंगी और भी
पार्ट इसके आएंगे तो आपको बिल्कुल टेंशन
नहीं लेना है मैं बिल्कुल एकदम बिगनर लेवल
से आपको लेकर चल रहा हूं एंड यकीन मानिए
न्यू न्यूक्लि आई को अगर आपने मास्टर कर
लिया आपने न्यूक्लि आई को यूज करना सही से
सीख लिया एंड अगर आप सही ऑप्शंस के साथ
सही टारगेट पे सही फ्लैक्स का यूज कर रहे
हैं तो न्यूक्लि आई एक टूल आपके बहुत सारे
काम कर देने वाला है और न्यूक्लि आई को आप
अलग-अलग दूसरे टूल्स के साथ भी कंजंक्शन
में यूज कर सकते हैं जैसे सब फाइंडर के
साथ आप यूज कर सकते हैं एसटीटीपी एक के
साथ आप यूज कर सकते हैं मतलब इधर से आपने
सब डोमेन फाइंड किया उस उस पे एसडीपी एक
चलाया लाइव डोमेन जो भी है उससे फिल्टर
आउट करके और उसको न्यूक्लि के टेंपलेट्स
पे पास ऑन कर दिया तो ये सारा काम आप एक
बार एक कमांड के थ्रू कर सकते हैं ऑटोमेशन
के थ्रू कर सकते हैं सिंपल एक ऑटोमेटेड
स्क्रिप्ट आप बैस्ट स्क्रिप्ट चला सकते
हैं फॉर वाइल लूप वगैरह फॉर का फॉर लूप का
यूज़ कर सकते हैं एक कंडीशन देके एंड आप
इसको यूज़ कर सकते हैं साथ में आप ले अ जो
न्यूक्लि आई है इसके वर्क फ्लो को यूज़ कर
सकते हैं टेंपलेट्स के अलावा वर्क फ्लो
काफी इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है वर्कफ्लो कुछ नहीं
है मैं आपको बताऊंगा क्या है अभी पहले हम
आगे बढ़ते हैं देन हम धीरे-धीरे सारी
चीजों को कवर करेंगे देयर आर मेनी मेनी
थिंग्स इन न्यूक्लि बहुत सारी चीजें हैं
लिटरली मैं बता रहा हूं न्यूक्लिया तुमने
सही से कर लिया
भाई तो आप अच्छी-अच्छी वने एबिलिटीज जो
आपके टारगेट है उसके अंदर फाइंड कर सकते
हो बस आपको थोड़ा डेडिकेशन चाहिए देना है
थोड़ा पेशेंस आपको रखना पड़ेगा एंड अगर
पॉसिबल हो तो वीपीएस के ऊपर न्यूक्लि को
इंस्टॉल कीजिए वीपीएस के ऊपर अपना मशीन
इंस्टॉल कीजिए काली या यवन टू उसमें
न्यूक्लि को इंस्टॉल कीजिए एंड वहां पे रन
कीजिए थोड़ा फास्ट आपका रन होगा अभी तो
मैं काली में कर रहा हूं बट वीपीएस का
तरीका मैंने ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ है डिजिटल
ओशियन वाली चीज बताई हुई है है आप वीपीएस
का इस्तेमाल कर सकते हैं एज सिंपल एज दैट
वीपीएस के लिए डिजिटल ओसियन के लिए अगर
आपको जाना है डिजिटल ओसियन के अ लाइक रेफर
वाले लिंक्स से हमारे तो आपको कुछ
क्रेडिट्स मिल जाते हैं तो आप यहां पे
जाके किसी भी वीडियो के लाइव वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाएंगे तो यहां पे आपको
हमने दे दिया है ये वाली लिंक इससे आप
जाके कर सकते हैं एज सिंपल एज दैट ठीक है
चलिए तो अब जो है हम यहां पे न्यूक्लि आई
के ऑफिशियल पहले गिट हब रिपोजिटरी पे आ
जाते हैं यहां पे एंड इसको स्क्रॉल करते
हैं जब आप स्क्रॉल करेंगे यहां पे तो आप
सिंपल पे देख सकते हैं न्यूक्लिया इज
यूज्ड टू सेंड रिक्वेस्ट अक्रॉस टारगेट्स
बेस्ड ऑन अ टेंप्लेट मैंने जैसे ही बताया
था कि टेंप्लेट पे बेस्ड सारा खेल है इसका
लीडिंग टू ज़ीरो फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स अब ऐसा
नहीं है ये गलत चीज है ये गलत मेंशन है
ठीक है कि जरो फॉल्स पॉजिटिव होगा ऐसा
नहीं है कुछ टूल है एक कोड है एक
प्रोग्रामिंग है एरर्स एंड प्रॉब्लम्स एंड
इश्यूज तो होते ही रहते हैं तो जीरो फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव जो है ये थोड़ा ज्यादा हो गया है
बट स्टिल काफी सही आपको जो रिस्पांस है
इसके आपको मिलते हैं ठीक है एंड प्रोवाइड
फास्ट स्कैनिंग ऑन अ लार्ज नंबर ऑफ होस्ट
ठीक है ओके ओबवियसली है बिकॉज ये पैरेलल
कांसेप्ट को भी यूज करता है पैरेलल
थ्रेड्स थ्रेडिंग वगैरह जो है एक तरह से
बोल सकते हैं चलाता है न्यूक्लियर ऑफर्स
स्कैनिंग फॉर अ वैरायटी ऑफ प्रोटोकॉल्स
इंक्लूडिंग टीसीपी डीएनएस एसटीपी ये सारे
प्रोटोकॉल्स के लिए काम करता है हु इज वेब
सॉकेट हैडलेस कोड ईटीसी ठीक है अब यहां पे
आते हैं तो ये कुछ इस तरीके के इसके
टेंपलेट्स होते हैं टेंपलेट्स पे हम बात
करेंगे आप देखेंगे क्रिएट योर ओन वाईएमएल
टेंप्लेट तो वाईएमएल टेंप्लेट कुछ इस
तरीके का होता है ठीक है जो आप खुद का
क्रिएट करेंगे हम बाद में देखेंगे तो
इसमें सिंपल सा फंडा है एक आईडी देनी होती
है जो नाम होता है आपका टेंप्लेट का
इंफॉर्मेशन के अंदर में आपको ऑथर का नाम
जो होता है वो दे दीजिए नेम दे दीजिए जो
भी नेम देना चाहते हैं सवेरिन कर दीजिए कि
कौन सी सीविरियस पे काम करता है जैसे इंफो
लो मीडियम हाई क्रिटिकल ऐसे सीवियरिंग
इसके टेंपलेट्स के होते हैं ठीक है तो आप
सीवियरिंग के बेसिस पे भी स्कैन कर सकते
हैं टेंपलेट्स का अभी हम उसको भी देखेंगे
उसके बाद रिक्वेस्ट कौन सा यूज़ हो रहा है
तो भैया मेथड गेट यूज़ हो रहा है पाथ कौन
से तो बेस यूआरएल अभी फिलहाल यहां पे जो
भी बेस यूआरएल होगा जो आप पास करेंगे वो
बेस यूआरएल यहां पे यहां पे सिंपल ये एज अ
वेरिएबल यहां पे ट्रीट हो रही है उसके बाद
यहां पे एक्सट्रैक्टर्स में बहुत सारी
चीजें आप मेंशन कर सकते हैं जैसे टाइप कौन
सा है रेक्स से पार्ट बॉडी है रेजस जो है
आपने यहां पे डिफाइन कर दिया तो यहां पे
डिफरेंट डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ तरीके जो य जो
केसेस हैं अ खुद के टेंपलेट्स क्रिएट करने
के वो मैं आपको बताऊंगा आगे चलके तो आप
खुद का भी टेंप्लेट क्रिएट कर पाएंगे
बेसिकली न्यूक्लि आई का जो काफी
इंपोर्टेंट होता है ठीक है
चलिए अब इनके ऑफिशियल ब्लॉक पोस्ट पे आ
जाते हैं न्यूक्लि आई टेंप्लेट को लेके
न्यूक्लि आई टेंप्लेट को लेके ऑफिशियल ब
ब्लॉग पोस्ट पे आ जाते हैं द अल्टीमेट
गाइड टू फाइंडिंग बक्स विद न्यूक्लि अब ये
काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है मैं आपको बता देता हूं
यहां पे देख सकते हैं आप न्यूक्लियर इंजन
यूज वाईएमएल बेस्ड टेंप्लेट टू डिफाइन द
स्टेप्स रिक्वायर्ड अ टू डिटेक्ट
अवेलेबिलिटी अब वाईएमएल की बात करें गाइज
तो वाईएमएल एक सिंपल सा लैंग्वेज आप बोल
सकते हैं या मार्कअप लैंग्वेज बोल सकते
हैं इसका एबरेविएट फॉर्म क्या होता है
वाईएमएल एंट मार्कअप लैंग्वेज ठीक है ना
जैसे आपने एचटीएमएल है ना हाइपरटेक्स्ट
मार्कअप लैंग्वेज ठीक है तो उसी तरीके से
यह एक वाईएमएल एंट मार्कअप लैंग्वेज है इज
अ डेटा सीरियल इजेशन लैंग्वेज व्हिच इज
डिजाइंड टू बी ह्यूमन फ्रेंडली एंड वर्क्स
वेल विद अदर प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेजेस फॉर
एवरी डे टास्क
दैट्ची है और कुछ भी नहीं क्या वर्क्स वेल
विथ अदर प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेजेस फॉर
एवरीडे टास्क्स तो वाईएमएल काफी इजी
लैंग्वेज है इजी आप इसको चाहे तो आप यहां
से ट्यूटोरियल्स पॉइंट के इन ट्यूटोरियल्स
के थ्रू इसको पढ़ सकते हैं समझ सकते हैं
थोड़ा हल्का-फुल्का ओवरव्यू ले सकते हैं
अदर वाइज मैं आपको बता दूंगा तो उतना काफी
आपके लिए हो जाएगा ठीक है तो चलिए अब यहां
पे आप देख सकते हैं ओपन सोर्स है यहां पे
कम्युनिटी ड्रिवन है ये उसके बाद यहां पे
आते हैं एंड सबसे पहले हम टेंप्लेट से
स्टार्ट करते हैं तो टेंप्लेट क्या है इज
अ वाईएमएल फाइल है बस और कुछ नहीं है
वाईएमएल एक फाइल है जिसके अंदर वाईएमएल के
अंदर जो भी कोड है वो लिखे होते हैं
न्यूक्लि कैन अंडरस्टैंड वेरियस नेटवर्क
प्रोटोकॉल्स एंड सर्विसेस अब न्यूक्लि जो
है एसटीटीपी के लिए पे भी काम करता है
डीएनएस पे भी काम करेगा एसएसएल पे भी रॉ
टीसीपी कम्युनिकेशंस पे भी काम करते हैं
वेब सॉकेट्स पे भी काम करते हैं आपके एंड
देयर आर लाइक हैडलेस देयर आर मल्टीपल
थिंग्स ठीक है नाउ यहां पे सबसे सिंपल
तरीका क्या है न्यूक्लि को रन करने का
न्यूक्लि आई दीजिए हाइन यू से टारगेट
मेंशन कीजिए या हाइन टारगेट भी ऑप्शन दे
सकते हैं एंड देन जो भी टारगेट है आपका वो
अगर पोर्ट नंबर आपको मेंशन करना है तो आप
यहां पे दे सकते हैं
दैट्ची है और कुछ भी नहीं उसके बाद यहां
देख लीजिए आप लोग इधर ध्यान दे दीजिए सभी
लोग इधर प्लीज
एवरीबॉडी वर्टिकल कॉरिलेशन से के थ्रू
जितने भी डोमेन सब डोमेन से फाइंड किए और
वो सारे पे आप न्यूक्लि चलाना चाहते हैं
तो आप सारे पे इसके थ्रू चला सकते हैं बस
एक टेक्स्ट फाइल में एक वन बाय लाइन वन
बाय वन लाइन बाय लाइन आप डाल दीजिए वहां
पे टारगेट्स को एंड दिस इज डन यू कैन रन
न्यूक्लियर ऑन दैट पर्टिकुलर थिंग ठीक है
अब आते हैं वर्क फ्लो के ऊपर थोड़ा समझते
हैं कि वर्कफ्लो क्या होता है तो देखो
वर्कफ्लो सिंपल सा क्या होता है ना मतलब
ये तो वर्कफ्लो अभी टूल के साथ है बट इसका
सिंपल सा एक खुद का भी वर्कफ्लो है उसपे
भी हम आएंगे फिलहाल ये दूसरे टूल्स के साथ
इसका आप वर्कफ्लो क्रिएट कर सकते हैं ठीक
है न्यूक्लि की एक वर्कफ्लो खुद की
वर्कफ्लो है दैट इज अ डिफरेंट थिंग वो मैं
अभी आऊंगा उस पे बट यहां पे यूजिंग
न्यूक्लि आई इन अ वर्कफ्लो विद अदर टूल्स
यानी कि अगर आप मान लो सब फाइंडर यूज करते
हो तो आप इस तरीके का कुछ एक बैश कोड भी
क्रिएट कर सकते हो बैश अ कमांड क्रिएट कर
सकते हो क्या कर सकते हो भैया
देखो सब फाइंडर सब फाइंडर के थ्रू आपको सब
डोमेन फाइंड करना है हाइ फन डी टारगेट
डोमेन जो भी है आपका हाइन साइलेंट
इन्होंने वो एक आर्गुमेंट दे दिया उसके
बाद एसटीटीपी एक आपने यूज किया ठीक है
आपने फाइंड किया एसटीटीपी एक पे जो भी
लाइव डोमस है अभी फिलहाल जो भी
प्रोटोकॉल्स है वो यहां पे दे दिया यहां
पे उसके बाद न्यूक्लि आई के कमांड रन कर
दिए न्यूक्लि हाइन t t यहां पे हमने
टेंप्लेट डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री पर्टिकुलर
टेंप्लेट के लिए यूज करते हैं एंड देन
आपको जो भी टेंप्लेट यूज करना है वो
टेंप्लेट जो
अ आपको मेंशन कर देना है ठीक है ये तो
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा ठीक है ये बहुत
इजी टू यूज है बहुत मैं आपको बताऊंगा बट
इसकी पावर आपको मैं दिखाऊंगा थोड़ी देर
में तो आपको जब लाइव अभी डेमोंस्ट्रेट
मिलेगी तो आपको इसका पावर जो है इसके पावर
का आईडिया होगा कि न्यूक्लि किस तरह का
पावरफुल टूल है ये ठीक है हां चलिए अब
यहां पे कुछ फिल्टरिंग टेंपलेट्स है
फिल्टरिंग टेंपलेट्स में क्या है देखो एट
द टाइम ऑफ राइटिंग देयर आर मेली 4000
कम्युनिटी डेवलप न्यूक्लियर टेंपलेट्स इन
द लाइब्रेरी द रेंज ऑफ टेंप्लेट इंक्लूड
डिटेक्शन फॉर नोन सीवीज कॉमन मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन एक्सपोज सेंसिटिव फाइल्स
टक्स
टैक्स फिंगरप्रिंटिंग एंड सो ऑन अब यहां
पे कुछ जो टेंपलेट्स हैं यहां पे
न्यूक्लियर प्रोवाइड सम ऑप्शंस फॉर मोर
इंटेलिजेंट एंड एफिशिएंट स्कैनिंग ऑफ
टारगेट्स इंस्टेड ऑफ डिफॉल्ट शॉटगन अप्रोच
ऑफ यूजिंग एवरी टेंप्लेट इन द लाइब्रेरी
अगेंस्ट द स्पेसिफाइड होस्ट अब होगा क्या
आप मुझे बताओ अगर मान लो हमने न्यूक्लि आई
टूल के जितने भी टेंपलेट्स है मान लो 8000
टेंपलेट्स है या जो भी है व्हाट एवर 8000
टेंप्लेट है मान लो अब 8000 टेंपलेट्स को
हम अगर किसी एक टारगेट पे एक साथ ही यूज
कर लेते हैं जस्ट फॉर एग्जांपल लेट्स सपोज
तो क्या होगा क्या पॉसिबिलिटी है मुझे
बताइए आप लोग चैट में ताकि आपके आपके
माइंडसेट को समझा जाए कि आपको कितना समझ
में आ रहा है या ये एक जेनरिक क्वेश्चन है
कि अगर हम किसी एक टारगेट पे इतने सारे
टेंपलेट्स एक साथ यूज करते हैं तो फिर
उसका आउटकम क्या हो सकता है व्हाट कुड बी
द आउटकम लेट मी नो इन द चैट आ सी द
चैट सी द चैट प्लीज बताइए सभी लोग बताइए
सभी लोग आंसर कीजिए
प्लीज क्रैश की बात तो ठीक है क्रश क्रश
की बात ठीक है बट स्टिल मैं आपको बता देता
हूं क्रश से ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट क्या है
मैं आपको बता देता हूं
टारगेट्स फायरवॉल्स
विल स्टार्ट ब्लॉकिंग द
रिक्वेस्ट क्या होगा कि रिक्वेस्ट जो है
ब्लॉक करना स्टार्ट कर देंगे आपकी जो
रिक्वेस्ट है एंड जो भी यहां पे ऐसे जैसे
मान लो कोई फायर वेल है बेसिकली आपकी पूरी
आईपी ब्लॉक अगर कर देता है या जो भी आप
रिक्वेस्ट भेजेंगे उसके बाद सबसीक्वेंट
रिक्वेस्ट जो है वो ब्लॉकड होगी तो आप जो
है इस न्यूक्लि टूल का फिर उस टारगेट पे
या उस पर्टिकुलर सर्विस के जो भी सर्विस
प्रोवाइड डर जो भी जिसे भी वो पर्टिकुलर
फायरवॉल जो है वो सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइड कर
रही होगी वो उस जगह पे आप यह टूल उस
पर्टिकुलर होस्ट पे या वेबसाइट पे आप ये
न्यूक्लि आई नहीं चला पाएंगे एंड आपकी
रिक्वेस्ट जो है ड्रॉप होती चली जाएगी और
आपको रिजल्ट आपके अकॉर्डिंग मिलेगा नहीं
तो आपको लगेगा कि भैया हमें रिजल्ट क्यों
नहीं मिल रहा व्हाई वी आर नॉट गेटिंग
रिजल्ट्स प्रॉपर रिजल्ट्स क्योंकि भैया हम
तो एकदम नॉर्मल सा चला रहे हैं कमांड डाल
रहे हैं भाई तो क्या दिक्कत है तो इस वजह
से आपको इस चीज से थोड़ा सा बचना है आपको
स्पेसिफिक ऑप्शन स्पेसिफिक फिक जो
टेंपलेट्स है उसका यूज़ करना है इसके अंदर
में ठीक है चलिए यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
एक ऑटोमेटिक सिलेक्शन भी होता है इसमें एक
ऑप्शन होता है दिस ऑप्शन अटेम्प्ट्स टू
फिंगरप्रिंट द टेक्नोलॉजी स्टैक एंड
कंपोनेंट्स यूज्ड ऑन द टारगेट देन सेलेक्ट
टेंपलेट्स दैट हैव बीन टैग्ड विथ दोज
टेक्स्ट टैक कीवर्ड एग्जांपल ठीक है तो अ
यहां पे कीवर्ड्स अ टेक्स्ट टैक कीवर्ड्स
अब एग्जांपल में क्या है जैसे अब यहां पे
हमने टारगेट मेंशन किया हाइफ ए लगा दिया
तो यहां पे बेसिकली इस इसमें वेपराइजर का
यूज किया जाता है मैं आपको अभी दिखाऊंगा
इसका सारा जो फंक्शन है सारा जो ऑप्शन है
वो दिखाऊंगा तो अभी आ जाते हैं न्यूक्लि
के हेल्प फाइल पे एंड यहां से अब हम इसको
समझते हैं ठीक है तो हम न्यूक्लि की हेल्प
फाइल पे आ चुके हैं अब हम एक टारगेट मेंशन
करते हैं एक टारगेट फिलहाल के लिए टारगेट
जो लेते हैं वो हमारी खुद की डि फ्रक्स को
ले लेते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है डि
फ्रक्स वी कैन टेक इट de.com को ठीक है
हमारी खुद की वेबसाइट ले लेते हैं टारगेट
में तो यहां प हम टारगेट की तरह अब यहां प
मेंशन कैसे करेंगे यह
देखिए दिस इज द टारगेट हमारा de.com
टारगेट है चलिए तो हमें क्या करना है पहले
न्यूक्लि आई एंटर करना है उसके बाद हमें
टारगेट मेंशन करना है न य अगर आपके पास
मल्टीपल टारगेट्स है तो हान l दीजिए लिस्ट
ऑफ टारगेट्स है टेक्स्ट फाइल के अंदर में
तो आप सिंपल जैसे आपने बहुत सारी आपने
क्या किया एक सब डोमस फाइंड कर ली हजारों
सब डोमस हैं तो हाइन एल दीजिए सिंगल
टारगेट के लिए हान u दे सकते हैं या हाइन
टारगेट लिख सकते हैं ठीक है उसके बाद यहां
पे आप नीचे की तरफ आइए नीचे की तरफ आएंगे
यहां पे तो यहां पे इनपुट मोड आप यहां पे
एंटर कर सकते हैं जैसे अगर मान लो आपके
पास कोई बर्प वाली रिजल्ट है ब ब शूट से
कोई रिजल्ट है तो आप यहां पे आईएम हान
आईएम बर्प लिख के बब शूट वाले रिजल्ट को
भी आप डायरेक्टली यहां पे इनपुट कर सकते
हैं बाय डिफॉल्ट यह लिस्ट मोड में यानी कि
नॉर्मल सी जो मोड है नॉर्मल मोड है वो
आपका लिस्ट मोड होता है बट अगर आपके पास
कोई जेसन एल है वाईएमएल फॉर्मेट है ओपन
एपीआई या स्वागा फॉर्मेट है तो आप वो भी
यहां पे मेंशन कर सकते हैं उसके बाद नीचे
आएंगे यहां पे तो आपके पास टेंपलेट्स वाला
ऑप्शन इंपॉर्टेंट है इसमें क्या है हान
एंटी जो ऑप्शन है ये आप लगा सकते हैं अगर
आप चाहते हैं कि आपके टारगेट पे सिर्फ जो
लेटेस्ट रिलीज में टेंपलेट्स ऐड हुए हैं
सिर्फ वही यहां पर रन करें तो आप यहां पे
हाइन एंटी ऑप्शन लगा सकते हैं तो यहां पे
मैं
अ ओ यहां पे कुछ स्पैमिंग चल रही है
तो स्पैमिंग मुझे हटाना पड़ेगा सर आई एम
प्रणव पाटिल आई इनवाइटेड यू टू बी माय ऑन
पॉडकास्ट बट आई हैव नॉट रिसीवड अ रिप्लाई
फ्रॉम योर टीम वी हैव शेड्यूल्ड द
रिकॉर्डिंग फॉर द सेवंथ कुड यू प्लीज लेट
मी नो इफ देयर इज एनी इशू प्रणो आई एम
टोटली बिज करेंटली तो सो एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी
बट आई कैन नॉट कम ऑन द पॉडकास्ट राइट नाउ
सो मैं अभी नेक्स्ट मंथ में फ्री होऊंगा
थोड़ा तो उस टाइम में हम जरूर कुछ ना कुछ
इस पे कर पाएंगे एंड वी विल हैव द
पॉडकास्ट तो प्लीज अगर आप उस टाइम तक वेट
कर पाए प्रणो तो प्लीज वेट ओके आई होप यू
अंडरस्टैंड मैं बहुत ज्यादा बिजी हूं मैं
बहुत अभी मैं क्लासेस अगर ले भी रहा हूं
ये क्लास भी ले रहा हूं तो मतलब मैं टाइम
को मैनेज करके ही ले पा रहा हूं क्योंकि
ऑफलाइन लेकर आना है डेनिक्स को एंड ऑफलाइन
लाने के पहले देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट
वी हैव टू गो थ्रू थ्रू एंड बहुत सारी
दिमाग पे बहुत सारी चीजें प्रेशर एंड बहुत
सारी चीजें हैं तो अ एंड सक्सेसफुल भी
बनाना है सब कुछ करना है लाइक और आपके लिए
भी कुछ जो बेनिफिट्स है बेनिफिशियल हो
आपको भी बहुत अच्छा लगे वैसा कुछ करना है
तो मैं काफी बिजी हूं तो करते हैं नेक्स्ट
मंथ में ठीक है हाइन एंटी आप लगा सकते हैं
देन हाइन टी हां अब यहां पे हाइन टी जो
ऑप्शन है ये आप यूज कर लीजिएगा ठीक है
हाइन टी आप इसको यूज क्यों कीजिएगा लिस्ट
ऑफ टेंपलेट्स और टेंप्लेट डायरेक्टरी टू
रन यानी कि अगर आपको टेंप्लेट रन करने हैं
ठीक है टेंपलेट्स कोई एक पर्टिकुलर
टेंप्लेट रन करना है या टेंप्लेट की पूरी
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
वो आपकी होम फोल्डर के अंदर में होम के
अंदर में या बोले रूट के अंदर में आप
जाएंगे तो यहां पे व्यू पे जाइएगा शो हिडन
फाइल्स पे क्लिक कर दीजिएगा ठीक है अगर
आपका नहीं होगा तो
देन यहां पर एक फाइल होगी डॉट लोकल यानी
लोकल लोकल डायरेक्टरी में जाइएगा तो
न्यूक्लि टेंपलेट्स करके यहां पे आपको
डायरेक्टरी मिलेगी इसमें चले जाइएगा इसमें
आपको सारी टेंपलेट्स जो है देखने को
मिलेंगी क्लाउड कोड डैश डीएसटी डीएनएस
फाइल हेड लिस्ट हेल्पर्स एटीटीपी
जावास्क्रिप्ट नेटवर्क पैसिव फिर यहां
प्रोफाइल्स एसएसएल एंड वर्कफ्लोज भी यहां
पे मिल जाएंगे ठीक है अब मान लो मुझे
एचटीटीपी के टेंप्लेट चाहिए तो मैं
एटीटीपी वाले में जाऊंगा तो एचटीटीपी के
सारे टेंपलेट्स आपको यहां पे मिल जाएंगे
कैसे यहां पे सी एनवीडी क्रेडेंशियल
स्टफिंग सीवीज डिफॉल्ट लॉगिंस एक्सपोज
पैनल्स एक्सपोज्स फजिंग हनी पॉट आईओटी
मिसलेनियस मिस कॉन्फिन ओसन टेकओवर्स
टेक्नोलॉजीज टोकन स्प्रे एंड वलने
एबिलिटीज अब मान लो मुझे वलने एबिलिटीज
वाली कोई अ आपको वलने बिलिटी वाली चाहिए अ
जो टेंपलेट्स है तो इस पे क्लिक करेंगे तो
आपको अलग-अलग डिवाइसेज अलग-अलग सर्विसेस
के वले एबिलिटीज के अकॉर्डिंग भी आपको
डायरेक्टली दिख जाएंगे एंड देन आपको यहां
पे डायरेक्ट कुछ टेंपलेट्स भी यहां पे दिख
जाएंगे सर्विसेस के अकॉर्डिंग अब जैसे मान
लो मुझे अचे के अंदर की अवेलेबिलिटीज के
टेंप्लेट चाहिए तो मैं इसको ओपन करूंगा तो
मुझे अचे के अवेलेबिलिटीज के जो भी
टेंप्लेट है यहां पे वाई एमएल फॉर्मेट में
देखने को मिल जाएगा इसके अंदर में लॉग 4 ज
वाली अलग से आपको मिल जाती है एंड शरो
वाली जो है अलग से आपको शरो
डिसेंट्रलाइजेशन की मिल जाती है तो आप इन
टेंपलेट्स को यूज़ कर पाएंगे अब मैं यहां
पे आपको दिखाता हूं इन टेंपलेट्स का
फॉर्मेट वैसा ही होता है जैसा कुछ टाइम
पहले मैंने आपको दिखाया था वाईएमएल वाली
फॉर्मेट होती है बस और कुछ भी नहीं होता
था जैसे मान लो यहां पे अ यहां पे अचे का
एन आई एफ आ एल आरईसी वाई एमएल जो है अ ये
वाली लोके आपकी टेंप्लेट है आरसी सॉरी
आरसी है रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन तो यहां पे
आप टेंप्लेट में देख सकते हैं यहां पे
आपको यहां पे आईडी देखने को मिलेगी ये आप
देख सकते हैं आईडी इंफो यहां पे आपको दी
गई है यहां पे रेफरेंसेस वगैरह दीी गए हैं
क्लासिफिकेशन की गई है यहां पे उसके बाद
यहां पे एचटीटीपी मेथड पाथ दिया गया है
मैचर कंडीशन लगाया गया है एंड याद रखिएगा
सीवियरिंग जरूर मेंशन होती है जो भी आपके
टेंपलेट्स होंगे इसकी सीवियरिंग देखो
क्रिटिकल है क्रिटिकल है अब ये जरूरी
क्यों है क्योंकि आप न्यूक्लि आई के थ्रू
सीवियरिंग के बेस पे भी स्कैन कर सकते हैं
अपने टारगेट को ठीक है अगर आप सीवियरिंग
अगर मान लो आपको क्रिटिकल सीवियरिंग स्कैन
करना टारगेट को तो जब आप कमांड डालेंगे तो
जितने भी क्रिटिकल वाले आपके टेंपलेट्स
होंगे वो सारे ऑटोमेटिक अप्लाई होते चले
जाएंगे एंड वो सबका यूज किया जाएगा
न्यूक्लिया के तरफ से उस टारगेट के
अगेंस्ट में ठीक है उसके बाद यहां पे कुछ
तरी हैं टेंपलेट्स के जिस तरीके से आप
टेंपलेट्स क्रिएट करते हैं वो सारे
कीवर्ड्स यहां पर मेंशन है लास्ट में जो
है आपका जो है एक्स्ट यूज करके टेंप्लेट
आपका कंप्लीट हो जाता है तो इस तरीके से
टेंपलेट्स आपको यहां प सारे टेंपलेट्स मिल
जाते हैं ठीक है अब इसी टेंप्लेट के अंदर
में यहां प एक वर्क फ्लोज भी होता
है वर्क फ्लो होता है वर्क फ्लो का क्या
है मैं आपको बता देता हूं जैसे मैं यहां
पे इसकी इसमें चला
गया सॉरी इसमें इस वाले में चलते हैं यहां
पे तो वर्कफ्लो में क्या है मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं जैसे मैं नीचे अभी नीचे आते हैं
अ ये रहा
वर्कफ्लो न w वर्क फ्लोस ठीक है क्या है
लिस्ट ऑफ वर्कफ्लो और वर्कफ्लो
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
बट ये स्पेसिफिक कंडीशंस के साथ है जो भी
ये वर्कफ्लोज हैं ये स्पेसिफिक कंडीशन के
साथ ये वर्कफ्लोज है यानी कि कोई
स्पेसिफिक कंडीशन मीट होगी तो यह टेंप्लेट
ऑटोमेटिक उस पर्टिकुलर टेंप्लेट को रन कर
देगा अब जैसे देखो मैं कोई सा भी एक
वर्कफ्लो ओपन कर लेता हूं जैसे अपाचे
वर्कफ्लो यह अपाचे वर्कफ्लो है इसको मैंने
ओपन किया इसको जूम इन थोड़ा कर लेता हूं
मैं आपके लिए अब यहां पे देखो आईडी क्या
है अचे वर्कफ्लो इंफो क्या है नेम अपाचे
वर्कफ्लो ऑथर यहां प ऑथर का नाम दिया हुआ
है जो भी नाम है आप देख लीजिएगा
डिस्क्रिप्शन है सिंपल वर्कफ्लो दैट रंस
ऑल अचे रिलेटेड न्यूक्लियर टेबल मतलब यह
वर्कफ्लो का मतलब समझ रही समझ ही रहे
होंगे राइट
मोहम्मद खान हेलो सर थैंक्स फॉर दिस बेस्ट
प्लेलिस्ट सर आप एक अलग से कभी वेब
आर्किटेक्चर के बारे में जिसमें बग बाउंट
कैसा सोचना चाहिए प्लीज बनाइए ठीक है बना
देंगे कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ठीक है वीपीटी
ट्रेनिंग का नेक्स्ट बैच कब से शुरू होगा
मे बी अप्रैल
अ ठीक है ठीक है टेंपलेट्स में अब यहां पे
यह क्या करेगा कि जितने भी अचे रिलेटेड
न्यूक्लि टेंपलेट्स है गिवन टारगेट पे उस
उसपे रन कर देगा बस सिंपल सा फंडा है ये
ये इसीलिए है ये वर्कफ्लो और कुछ भी नहीं
है ठीक है अब
देखो टेंप्लेट कौन सी टेंप्लेट आपकी ये है
कौन सी अचे डिटेक्ट डवा एए इस टेंप्लेट को
रन कर देगा एंड सब टेंपलेट्स में इन्होंने
टैग डाला हुआ है टैग्स के थ्रू भी आप जो
है आप न्यूक्लि आई को चला सकते हैं जैसे
आपको सीवीज के टेंपलेट्स का यूज करना है
तो आप हाई फन टैग्स देके आप सीवी लिख
दीजिएगा तो सीवीज वाले जो टेंपलेट्स है वो
वहां पे रन करने लगते हैं रन होने लगते
हैं ठीक है तो ये आपका सिंपल सा वर्क फ्लो
है और कुछ नहीं है ये एक टेंप्लेट है कुछ
कंडीशंस के साथ अब जैसे यहां
पे मैं देखता हूं अ वपस का कुछ है हां वपस
का भी है यहां पे तो वपे वाली ओपन कर लेते
हैं यहां पे अब देखिए वर्डप्रेस वर्कफ्लो
में क्या है वर्डप्रेस सिक्योरिटी चेक्स
एंड यहां पे सिंपल वर्कफ्लो दैट रंस ऑल
वर्डप्रेस लेटेड न्यूक्लियर टेंपलेट्स ऑन
अ गिवन टारगेट एंड यहां पे कौन सा है
वर्डप्रेस डिटेक्ट y एए एंड वर्डप्रेस का
टैग यहां पे दिया हुआ है तो ये आपके
वर्डप्रेस वाली जो भी टेंपलेट्स है उसको
यहां पे रन कर दिए जाएंगे बस तो सिंपल सा
ये बहुत सा फंडा है वर्कफ्लो का सिंपल सा
फंडा है आपके टेंपलेट्स का चलिए अब यहां
पे आ जाते हैं फिर से तो यहां पे हमने
एंटी का यूज़ किया था अब हमने टी
टेंपलेट्स के लिए हम करेंगे यहां पे यूज़
वर्कफ्लो के लिए हान w यूज़ कर लेंगे अगर
आपको वर्कफ्लो यहां पे डिफाइन करनी है
वर्कफ्लो आपको बतानी है तो उसके बाद यहां
पे आप आएंगे तो यहां पे हान टीएल का यूज़
करेंगे तो लिस्ट ऑल अवेलेबल टेंप्लेट
जितने भी टेंप्लेट हैं वो सारे टेंपलेट्स
यहां पे लिस्ट आपके हो जाएंगे न टीजीएल
करेंगे तो लिस्ट ऑल अवेलेबल टैग्स अब ये
टैक्स जो है ना हाइन टीजीएल टैक्स ये काफी
इंपोर्टेंट चीज है जैसे मैं क्या करता हूं
न्यूक्लि आई हाइन टीजीएल करता हूं तो
जितने भी टैग्स है ना आपके न्यूक्लि के
अंदर में वो सारे यहां पे लिस्ट होके आ
जाएंगे जैसे देखिए यहां पे कितने सारे
टैक्स है ये सारे टैग्स है अब जैसे मान लो
मैं ऊपर की तरफ चलता हूं ठीक है मैं कितने
टैक्स है लगभग कितने टैक्स है इसको एक बार
काउंट कर लेते हैं
राइट लेट्स
काउंट टोटल टैक्स जो है वो है आपके
5723 तो 5000 723 टैग्स है अब इसमें आप
देख सकते होंगे चलिए ऊपर की तरफ पेज अप कर
लेते हैं इसको हम ऊपर की तरफ लेके चलते
हैं
इनको देर आर मल्टीपल टैक्स ठीक है ये सारे
टैक्स हैं तो अगर मान लो आपको जैसे यह
वाली टैग सर्विस टैग आपको यूज करना है तो
सर्विस टैग जो है आप उसको यूज कर सकते हैं
सीवी 2013 तो आप इसको यूज कर सकते हैं
सीवी 2008 उसके अंदर 15 आपके जो है
टेंपलेट्स बेसिकली रन करेंगे तो आप इसको
यूज़ कर सकते हैं तो इतने टैग्स हैं उसके
अंदर कितने टेंपलेट्स हैं वह सारे यहां पे
दिए गए हैं उस पर्टिकुलर टैग के लिए उतने
टेंप्लेट जो है आपके रन करेंगे जैसे सबसे
ज्यादा सीवी के लिए है अगर आपको सीवी
सिर्फ आप टैक्स मेंशन करते हैं तो 2685
टेंपलेट्स लगभग उस टारगेट के अगेंस्ट जो
है वह एग्जीक्यूट होंगे और उतनी सारी जो
चीज़ें हैं वनबिल उस तरह उस सीवी से
रिलेटेड वनबिल फाइंड करके देता है
वर्डप्रेस रिलेटेड 1023 टेंपलेट्स है तो
अगर आप हान टैग्स करके अ वर्डप्रेस अ के
किसी टारगेट के अगेंस्ट करना चाहते हैं तो
आप यह वाला टैग यूज बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं
ठीक है समझ में आपको शायद आ रहा
होगा ठीक है चलिए तो टैक्स वाला सीन आपको
समझ में आ गया होगा अब आ जाते हैं यहां पे
फिर से मैं यहां पे एक बार नीचे आ जाता
हूं एंड यहां पे इसको क्लियर कर देते हैं
एंड देन अगेन न्यूक्लि हा फच कर लेते हैं
एंड अगेन वापस ऊपर चल जाते हैं ये ये बहुत
जरूरी है समझना जो मैं आपको अभी समझा रहा
हूं गाइस बहुत लोग न्यूक्लि के ऊपर बहुत
सारे आपको कंटेंट एंड बहुत सारी चीजें
आपको मिल जाएंगी बट बिगनर फ्रेंडली बहुत
कम आपको मिलेंगे ऑनलाइन इंटरनेट के ऊपर
में जो न्यूक्लि को बहुत बिगनर बेसिक लेवल
से समझाता हो क्योंकि यह समझना बहुत जरूरी
है जब आप ये समझ जाएंगे तो आप न्यूक्लि आई
को चुटकियों में यूज करेंगे न्यूक्लि यूज
करना आपके लिए बाएं हाथ का खेल होगा एंड
आप तुरंत बहुत इफिस एफिशिएंटली जो है ना
आप न्यूक्लियर को यूज कर पाएंगे वले
एबिलिटीज फाइंड कर पाएंगे ठीक
है चलिए तो ये तो हमने देख लिया कहां थे
हम फिल्टरिंग में नहीं फिल्टरिंग में नहीं
थे फिल्टरिंग से ऊपर थे हम टेंपलेट्स के
अंदर में थे तो हमने डबल वर्कफ्लो देख
लिया एंड टीएल टेंपलेट्स के लिए टीजीएल
यहां पे आपके जितने भी टैग्स है उसको रन
लिस्ट करने के लिए फिल्टरिंग वाले ऑप्शंस
पे आते हैं तो अगर आपको फिल्टरिंग ऑप्शंस
लगाना है तो लगा सकते हैं जैसे हाइन टैग्स
ठीक है आप फिल्टर करने के लिए टेंपलेट्स
टू रन बेस्ड ऑन टैग्स तो यहां पे जितने
टैग्स मेंशन वहां पे टैक्स थे हमारे पास
तो हाइन टैग्स आप लिख के और आप जैसे
वर्डप्रेस करना चाहते हैं तो आप वर्डप्रेस
मेंशन कर दीजिए
दैट्ची चलते हैं जैसे अब मान लो न्यूक्लि
मैं कर रहा हूं एंड h u मैं टार्गेट दे
रहा हूं टारगेट क्या दे रहा हूं एपस कॉलन
dex.com क्योंकि नक् वपे के ऊपर है तो मैं
यहां पे हाई फन टैक्स दे रहा हूं एंड यहां
पे मैं वर्डप्रेस लिख दे रहा हूं ठीक है
सिंपल हाई फन टैक्स एंड वर्डप्रेस अब मैं
एंटर करूंगा तो अभी आप देखिए क्या होगा
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं एग्जांपल में ये
देखिए यहां पे आपने देखा टेंप्लेट लोडेड फ
फॉर करंट स्कैन सिर्फ 1023 टेंपलेट जबकि
है 8000 कुछ बट न्यूक्लि आई यहां पे सिर्फ
वर्डप्रेस वाली जो टैग जो वर्डप्रेस वाली
टेंपलेट्स है ना उसको बस उठा रहा है एंड
उन टेंपलेट्स को ही रन करेगा इस पर्टिकुलर
fish.com के अगेंस्ट एंड आपको फिर यहां पे
रिजल्ट ज लाके आपको देगा ठीक है अब यहां
पे टेंपलेट्स क्लस्टर्ड हो चुके हैं 10
रिड्यूस फाइव रिक्वेस्ट अब यहां पे ये
क्लस्टर्ड का मतलब क्या है ना न्यूक्लि आई
बहुत स्मार्टली थोड़ा वर्क करता है जैसे
कि मान लो कि एक टारगेट पे अगर आप 10
रिक्वेस्ट भेज रहे हैं ना टेंपलेट्स के तो
वो उसको क्लस्टर्ड कर देता है ठीक है
रिक्वेस्ट एक ही भेजेगा और 10 टेंपलेट्स
उसको 10 तरीके से हैंडल करेंगे उस
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट को समझ में आ रहा है
आपको ये समझ में आ रहा है तो ये एफिशिएंट
बनाता है आपके स्कैनिंग को तो ज्यादा
डिटेक्शंस ना हो जो फायरवॉल्स है वो
ज्यादा प्रॉब्लम ना करें आपके रिक्वेस्ट
को ज्यादा ब्लॉक ना किया जाए इसकी वजह से
न्यूक्लि क्लस्टर्ड का जो तरीका है
क्लस्टर्ड उसको यूज करता है रिक्वेस्ट
करने के लिए हालांकि आप इसमें रेट
लिमिटिंग एंड ये चीजें लगा सकते हैं रेट
लिमिटिंग वगैरह तो उसमें आप बिल्कुल आप जो
है रेट लिमिट का यूज करके एंड एग्जीक्यूट
कर सकते हैं अब देखिए यहां पे एक चीज मैं
आपको बताता हूं कि यहां पे आपको रिजल्ट्स
मिलने शुरू हो चुके हैं ठीक है आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे वी आर स्टार्टेड गेटिंग
रिजल्ट्स एंड यह वर्डप्रेस वाली जितने भी
स्कैनिंग है वह सारी स्कैनिंग यहां पे
आपकी चालू हो चुकी है यह आप देख सकते हैं
ठीक है तो यहां पर कुछ इंफो वाली मिल रही
है यहां
पे वला बिटीज
ठीक है यहां पर एक सीवी के अगेंस्ट भी
हमारे को मिली है लेबिलिटी हाई लेबिलिटी
मिली है सीवी के अगेंस्ट यह क्योंकि हम एक
ओल्ड वर्जन का एक जो बेसिकली प्लगइन है
उसको यूज कर रहे हैं ट्स वई यह है जो कि
हमें नोन है तो आप इसको प्लीज हमें
रिपोर्ट मत कीजिएगा ये ऑलरेडी नो नहीं ये
ठीक ठीक है क्योंकि हम ओल्ड यूज कर रहे
हैं एक तरह से आप मान सकते हैं कि उसको हम
अभी लेटेस्ट में नहीं कर सकते ट्स वई दैट
इज डिटेक्टेड तो यहां पे आपको रिजल्ट्स
आने स्टार्ट हो जाएंगे ठीक
है अब यहां पर रिजल्ट आने स्टार्ट हो र
हैं अब देखिए यहां पे इसमें बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग रिजल्ट्स आएंगे अब जैसे
वर्डप्रेस मेल चम फॉरवर्ड डिटेक्टेड वर्जन
यहां पे डिटेक्ट हुआ है वर्जन 4 प यहां पे
9.16 उसके बाद वन क्लिक डेमो वर्जन
डिटेक्शन हुआ है ये सारे इंफॉर्मेशन वाले
ये सारी इनकी सीवियरिंग इंफॉर्मेशन वाली
है इंफो वाली सवेरिया लो सवेरिया एक हाई
सवेरिन पे डिटेक्ट हुई है आपकी उसके बाद
बाकी सारे जो हैं वो लो इंफो सवेरिन ही लो
सवेरिन हमें अभी तक खास नहीं मिला है एक
हाई मिली है बाकी तो सारे नॉर्मल ही है तो
ऐसे ही ये स्कैन चलता रहेगा 1000 कुछ
टेंप्लेट जो है उसपे स्कैनिंग चलेगी एंड
आपको यहां पे रिजल्ट देखने को मिलेगा तो
अभी देखते जाइए जब आप इसको वीपीएस पे
करेंगे क्लाउड सिस्टम पे किसी तो ये काफी
फास्ट होता है तो मैं आपको ऑलरेडी बता
चुका हूं हमारी वीडियोस हमारी क्लासेस में
ऑलरेडी क्लाउड सेटअप कैसे करेंगे डिजिटल
ओसन के अंदर क्लाउड में कैसे आप अपनी मशीन
को इंस्टॉल कर पाएंगे एंड एवरीथिंग ठीक
है सर लोकल में टेंप्लेट नहीं है न्यूक्लि
को इंस्टॉल कर लिया आपने ए इंस्टॉल
न्यूक्लि से उसके बाद आप न्यूक्लि आई को
एक बार रन कीजिए तो टेंपलेट्स इंस्टॉल
होंगे देन आप जाइए रूट या होम में एंड देन
आप डॉट लोकल में जाइए ठीक है आपको मिल
जाएगा ओके आएंगे अभी पल्लव उस पर भी आएंगे
अभी सब कुछ बताएंगे अभी एपीआई वाली चीज
अभी आई नहीं है तो अभी आएंगे तो उस परे
सारा कुछ क्लियर होगा ठीक है नॉर्मल सी
चीज है ठीक है पल्लव आई होप यू गट थोड़ा
वेट
कीजिए ये बॉय आपको मिल गया यह बॉय करके जो
है चलिए तो ये हमने
एक तो मैंने एग्जांपल समझाने के लिए आपको
कि किस तरीके से आप टैग्स का यूज कर सकते
हैं वो मैंने यहां पे मेंशन कर दिया तो
यहां पे हाइन टैक्स हमने यहां पे दे दिया
ठीक है
चलिए अब यहां पर आ जाते हैं फिल्टरिंग के
ऊपर
में हाय सर मेरा नाम सीमांता है मैं
बांग्लादेश से हूं मैंने पहले से देखना
शुरू किया क्या बात है कोई बात नहीं कोई
बात नहीं आप देख सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम जो
लोग यहां पर आए हैं लाइक ठोकते जाइए अरे
वाह यार 109 लाइक कर दिया लोगों ने अभी भी
अंदर से जोश कम नहीं हुआ तुम लोगों में यह
मेरे को काफी अच्छा लगा क्योंकि अभी तो
बहुत कुछ बचा हुआ है जितना तुम जोशीले तुम
रहोगे उससे ज्यादा डबल जोशीला मैं रहूंगा
बीच में थोड़ा मतलब अभी थोड़ी स्लो रहेगी
आपकी जो यह फ्रीक्वेंसी है क्लासेस की बट
बहुत जल्दा हम इसको फिर से बैक टू सेम
फ्रीक्वेंसी लेकर आएंगे आपको पता ही
ऑफलाइन कोच जो हमारी कंपनी है उसके
रिगार्डिंग काम चल रही है बहुत सारी चीजें
तो इस वजह
से गुड गुड गुड गुड गुड रन करो अब यहां पे
टैक्स का मतलब आप समझ गए टैक्स के
अकॉर्डिंग जो भी आपकी टेंपलेट्स है उसको
यहां पे ये चला के दे देगा अब यहां य पे ई
टैग्स यहां पे एक्सक्लूड टैग्स मतलब
टेंपलेट्स टू एक्सक्लूड बेस्ड ऑन टैग्स
मतलब अगर आप चाहते हैं कोई पर्टिकुलर
टैक्स को एक्सक्लूड करके चलाना तो आप इसको
इसके थ्रू चला सकते हैं आईडी यहां पे
टेंप्लेट टू रन बेस्ड ऑन टेंप्लेट आईडी तो
आईडी के ऊपर भी आप चला सकते हैं आईडी जो
मेंशन होती है स्टार्टिंग में आपके
टेंप्लेट के अंदर में ठीक है ई आईडी वही
एक्सक्लूड आईडी वही और कुछ नहीं है नथिंग
एल्स तो यहां पे एक और ऑप्शन है हान s या
हाइ फन
सीवियरिंग जो है आप रन कर सकते हैं को
यानी जितने टेंप्लेट जिसम जो इंफो या लो
या मीडियम या हाई या क्रिटिकल सरि वाले
टेंप्लेट होंगे व आप स्पेसिफिक एक टारगेट
पर चला सकते हैं लिस्ट ऑफ टारगेट पर चला
सकते हैं तो अगर आपको चाहिए कि नहीं मुझे
सिर्फ और सिर्फ मीडियम
सीविरियस करने हैं तो यह कहां पे मीडियम
टेंपलेट्स है कौन से हैं पता कैसे चलेगा
तो जैसे मान लो
मैंने एचटीटीपी
पे डिफॉल्ट लॉगिन प चलते एंड यहां पे यहां
पर चलते हैं अचे पे यहां पर मान लो यह
टेंप्लेट है तो इसके अंदर ही लिखा हुआ
रहता है ये टेंप्लेट हाई है सवेरिन है
क्या है तो आप देखेंगे सीविरियस
की कैटेगरी में टेंप्लेट आएगा यानी जैसे
ही हम वहां पे हाइफ एस देके हाई मेंशन
करेंगे यह टेंप्लेट भी ऑटोमेटिक यूज में आ
जाएगा तो इसके कहने का मतलब है कि मैं अगर
इस तरीके से कुछ रन करूं यहां क्लियर कर
देता हूं
कहां गया भाई सेकंड वाला
हमारा हां जी तो मैं अगर इस तरीके से करूं
न्यूक्लि आई एंड हाइन य यहां पे मैं अपना
टारगेट डिफाइन कर दूं एडीपीएस कॉलन स् स्
डिफर कॉ एंड यहां पे हमने टारगेट दे दिया
सॉरी ये मैं इसके अंदर क्यों दे रहा हूं
यार यहां पे हमने
hs.com यहां प दे दिया अब यहां पे हम क्या
कर फन s के थ्रू यहां मैं मीडियम कर देता
हूं ठीक है मैं मीडियम कर देता हूं सपोज
और मैं अगर इसको रन करता हूं मीडियम वाले
हाई फन ए सीवियरिंग के अकॉर्डिंग तो जो
सीवियरिंग के अकॉर्डिंग जितने भी
टेंपलेट्स होंगे वो सारे लोड होंगे जैसे
आप देखो टेंपलेट्स लोडेड फॉर करंट स्कैन
1560 यानी कि हाई यानी कि मीडियम सिरिटी
वाले 1560 टेंपलेट्स हैं टोटल जो कि यहां
पे एग्जीक्यूट हो रहे हैं रन हो रहे हैं
एंड ये आपके पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के अगेंस्ट
रन होंगे एंड आपको स्कैन करके आपकी जो वले
एबिलिटीज है वो आपको प्रोवाइड करेंगे तो
अभी देखो यहां पे स्टार्ट हुआ है अगर कोई
मीडियम अ सीरि की लेबिलिटी मिलती है तो
आपको मिल जाएगा यहां रिजल्ट अदर वाइज ये
बोल देगा कि नहीं भया हमें कुछ मिला नहीं
है ठीक
है ठीक है बहुत अच्छी बात है टेंप्लेट
आपको मिल गया तो हेलो सर मैं आपके चैनल पे
अरहम जावेद नया हूं थैंक यू सो मच सर न्यू
कोर्स बाय किया है वो भी ऐसा पढ़ाते है
जैसे फ्री में नॉलेज देता है क्या बात है
बहुत बहुत
बढ़िया एलीना
पात्रा आप टीचिंग बहुत बेसिक से समझा रहे
हो जो कि हम लोग जैसे बिगनर के लिए बहुत
बहुत गोल्ड पाथ बना रहे फ्यूचर के लिए
थैंक यू सर फॉर सपोर्ट ू आर स या वेलकम
एलीना पात्रा एंड थैंक यू फॉर योर वर्ड्स
तो मैं बेसिक से ही पढ़ाना प्रेफर करता
हूं क्योंकि काफी सारे बिगिनर्स होते हैं
एंड बिगिनर्स को पढ़ाने वाले लोग लोगों की
कमी है जो उनको समझा पाए एक्चुअली मुझे
लगता है मैं समझा पाता हूं तो उसी तरीके
से आपको कुछ रिजल्ट मिलते हैं तो यहां पे
फिलहाल शायद मीडियम में कुछ भी हमें नहीं
मिल रहा है तो यहां पे आपको कोई रिजल्ट
यहां पे शायद ना मिल रहा हो बट इसी यम
सीवियरिंग को अगर हम इंफो कर देते हैं
इंफो वाली तो देखिए आपको रिजल्ट्स मिलने
स्टार्ट हो जाएंगे क्योंकि इंफो के
रिजल्ट्स एक्चुअली हमारे पास थे इस
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के लिए पहले तो यहां पे
आप टेंप्लेट हो गए 3801 3801 टेंप्लेट
हमारे आ चुके हैं एंड यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं डीएनएस वफ डिटेक्टेड क्लाउड फ्लेयर एक
इंफो मिली है हमें डेनिक्स के लिए तो यह
एक आ गया हमारे पास और भी बहुत सारे
रिजल्ट्स आपको देखने को मिल सकते हैं इसके
साथ ठीक है सर वाचिंग फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान
ग्रेट सर चलो बहुत बढ़िया धन्यवाद
भाई उदयपुर से राजस्थान से य मैंने तो
पूछा ही नहीं यार आप लोग आप लोग ने वैसे
ही चलो बढ़िया जब शुरू कर दिया तो बता ही
दो कौन कौन कहां कहा से है कहां कहा से
देख रहे हैं आप लोग इंडिया से इंडिया में
कहां से अगर बाहर से तो बाहर में कहां से
है
जोधपुर ब्रो थैंक्स क्योंकि मैंने बग
बांटी का कोर्स लिया था 10000 में बट
उसमें भी ऐसा ना समझाया और ना पढ़ाया मैं
मैंने तो पहले ही आपको चैलेंज किया था सभी
लोगों को गारंटी दी थी कि आपको पेड बग
बाउटी के क्लास में भी अगर इतना मिल जाए
तो मैं मैं समझ जाऊंगा कि यह क्लासेस मैं
अच्छे से नहीं करा रहा या इसमें वर्थ ये
वर्थ नहीं है बट आपको नहीं मिलेगा नेपाल
नेपाल ठीक
है उत्तराखंड नैनीताल क्या बात है यार
अच्छी जगह से हो भाई लव फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान
लव फ्रॉम इंडिया ब्रदर
फ्रॉम कोलकाता पल्लव अच्छा बढ़िया ज्ञानेश
उड़ीसा गुजरात से नाइट्रो गेमिंग क्या बात
है यार आंध्र प्रदेश साईं कुमार शुभम
कुमार प्रणाम सर प्रणाम
ब्रदर राहुल एनजे मोतिहारी क्या बात है या
मोतिहारी वाले भी
है अब पता है मुझे वह फेक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है
फेक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है एपीएस हैकर मिस्टर
एपीएस हैकर्स वो लोग फेक फेक एक पंती करते
हैं उनसे बच के रहिए एंड कुछ
ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस जो है हमारा नाम यूज कर रहे
हैं हमें पता चला हमें हमारे टीम से मुझे
पता चला कि हमारा नाम डेनिक्स का नाम यूज
करके एंड बोल रहे है कि आपको टूल्स देंगे
आपको पेनड्राइव में ये देंगे वो देंगे और
वो लिटरली दे आर यूजिंग आवर नेम्स तो भाई
उनके बातों में मत आ जाना डेनिक्स कोई कुछ
ऐसा काम नहीं करती है पहली बात और डेनिक्स
के जो नंबर्स हैं वही नंबर्स हमारे
ऑफिशियल है दो नंबर्स जो हैं वही नंबर
हमारे ऑफिशियल है एक वेबसाइट है और एक
आपका 9065 जो है 7748 यह दो नंबर्स है
मेनली और भी कुछ नंबर्स है बट वो हमारे
नहीं होते हैं जो आपको कांटेक्ट करते हैं
राइट तो यहां पर आपके पास ऑप्शन सारी यहां
पर रिजल्ट जो है आपके आ चुके हैं इंफो
वाली जितने भी थे वह सारे यहां पर लिस्ट
आउट हो चुके हैं चलिए अब यहां पर
न्यूक्लियर हाफ प आते हैं और कुछ और भी
चीजों को इसको थोड़ा समझते हैं
देखिए कोल्लापुर
बांग्लादेश बृजनंदन बिहार ग्रेट म बिहार
क्या बात है यार बहुत सारे हैं बिहार
वाले सागर मध्य प्रदेश ठीक है
कंबल सर मैंने युवराज गुप्ता बोल रहे हैं
सर मैंने अभी रिसेंटली साइबर सेल पुलिस
ऑफिसर्स को हाउ वे वेब वरे बिलिटी हेल्प
इन इन्वेस्टिगेशन की वेबीनार होस्ट की थी
थैंक यू आपकी नॉलेज का बहुत फायदा मिला
क्या बात है युवराज मेनी मेनी
कांग्रेचुलेशन मुझे काफी मजा आता है जब
ऐसे कोई बोलता है ना कि हां भैया मतलब
मैंने कोई होस्ट किया है मेरे बहुत सारे
स्टूडेंट्स ने वेबिनार्स सेमिनार्स वगैरह
भी अ ऑर्गेनाइज करी है तो आई फील प्राउड
कि दे आर डूइंग सच थिंग्स एंड अगर मेरी जो
नॉलेज है अगर उनके थोड़ी भी काम आई हो तो
सो ग्रेट ऑफ यू एंड कांग्रेचुलेशन सो यहां
पे हमने अ ऊपर में ऊपर में देखा था यहां
पे ऊपर आते हैं ऊपर आते हैं ऊपर आते
हैं हां जी फिल्टरिंग वाले ऑप्शंस पे थे
तो हमने फिल्टरिंग का ऑप्शंस यहां पे यूज़
किए हैं बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस आप यूज़ कर सकते
हैं आउटपुट मोड अगर आपको आउटपुट किसी एक
फाइल में चाहिए तो आप न ओ लगा सकते हैं
आउटपुट फाइल टू राइट फाउंड इश्यूज जो भी
इश्यूज है उनको एक फाइल में आपको मंगाना
चाहते हैं तो आप हान ओ लगा सकते हैं ठीक
है यहां पे आप एस आरई एसपी यानी एस रेस्प
का यूज या स्टोर रिस्पांस का यूज़ कर सकते
हैं स्टोर ऑल रिक्वेस्ट या रिस्पांस पास
थ्रू न्यूक्लि आई टू आउटपुट डायरेक्टरी
ठीक है जो भी रिक्वेस्ट रिस्पांस है उसको
स्टोर कर लेगा यहां पे न एस आईडी यूज़ कर
सकते हैं स्टोर रेस्पॉन
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
जें हैं जो आप देख लीजिए एक बार यहां पे
कॉन्फ़िग स्ट्रिंग है पाथ टू द न्यूक्लि
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल अगर आपको कोई
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल यहां पे मेंशन करनी है
तो आप यहां पे मेंशन कर सकते हैं प्रोफाइल
स्ट्रिंग यहां पे प्रोफाइल लिस्ट वगैरह ये
सारी चीजें मेंशन कर सकते हैं इसमें एक
चीज और है यहां पे हाइन ए तो अगर आप कोई
हेडर स्ट्रिंग डालना चाहते हैं अपने
सबसीक्वेंट रिक्वेस्ट के साथ में तो आप
हान एच डाल के कोई भी हेडर डाल सकते हैं
हर एक रिक्वेस्ट में अगर आप चाहते हैं
उसको भेजना तो हान एच के थ्रू आप वो भेज
सकते हैं ठीक
है ओके क्लस्टरिंग डिसेबल करनी है तो कर
सकते हैं बट डिसेबल मत कीजिएगा बढ़िया
रहेगा क्लस्टरिंग इनको होने दीजिए जो इनका
नॉर्मल सा सिनेरियो है ठीक है उसके बाद
यहां पे आप आएंगे यहां पे नीचे की तरफ आ
जाइए नीचे की तरफ आ जाइए एक जो इंपॉर्टेंट
चीज है मैं आपको बता देता हूं
हम फजिंग फजिंग में आइए फजिंग में यहां पे
आप हान एटी का यूज कर सकते हैं फजिंग टाइप
स्ट्रिंग में ओवरराइड्स फजिंग टाइप सेट इन
टेंपलेट्स तो जो भी टेंपलेट्स के अंदर में
रिप्लेस प्रीफिक्स पोस्टफिक्स इन फिक्स जो
भी यहां पे फजिंग के आपके अ टाइप्स हैं
ठीक है ना उनको यह बेसिकली क्या कर देता
है ओवरराइड कर देता है तो फिलहाल आपको यह
जरूरत नहीं है यूज़ करने के लिए नॉर्मल आप
यूज कीजिए कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ठीक है
यहां पे आप फज का यूज करके लोडिंग इनेबल
लोडिंग फजिंग टेंप्लेट जो होते हैं उसको
आप यूज कर सकते हैं हालांकि यहां पे
डिप्रेशिएट कर दिया गया है तो आपको हाइन
डीएसटी यूज करना है इसके बदले में तो
डीएसटी इनेबल या रन डीएसटी यानी फज
न्यूक्लि आई टेंपलेट्स तो जो भी यहां पे
फजिंग के टेंपलेट्स है आप इसको डीएसटी के
थ्रू यूज कर सकते हैं एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते
हैं
चलिए आप डायरेक्ट भी यूज़ कर सकते हैं
डायरेक्टरी का देके यहां पे न t करके
डायरेक्टरी का देके अब मैं आपको बताऊंगा
कैसे डायरेक्टरी का कैसे दे वो भी बताऊंगा
ठीक है यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए यह जरूरी
नहीं है आपके लिए रेट लिमिट जो है इसका
यूज आप जरूर कर सकते हैं रेट लिमिट को आप
थोड़ा कम कर दीजिएगा देखिए इनका जो
डिफॉल्ट नंबर ऑफ रिक्वेस्ट टू सेंड पर
सेकंड है 150 है यह काफी ज्यादा होता है अ
डिटेक्शन काफी ज्यादा इसमें हो सकती है तो
इसको आप थोड़ा लोअर कर दीजिएगा कम कर
दीजिएगा जो भी इसके जो यह आपका डिफॉल्ट
वैल्यू है 150 इसको आप 50 कर दीजिए या 30
कर दीजिए ज्यादा बेटर होगा आरएलडी इसकी
जरूरत आपको है नहीं डिफॉल्ट वन सेकंड है
रहने दीजिएगा इस इसकी भी जरूरत नहीं है
कुछ वैसे भी डिप्रेशिएट हो चुकी है ये
बीएस आप यूज कर सकते हैं मैक्सिमम नंबर ऑफ
होस्ट्स टू बी एनालाइज्ड इन पैरेलल पर
टेंप्लेट डिफॉल्ट 25 है रहने भी दे सकते
हैं छोड़ भी सकते हैं हान c वाली सेट कर
सकते हैं डिफॉल्ट इसका 25 है इसको थोड़ा
कम कर सकते हैं मैक्सिमम नंबर ऑफ
टेंपलेट्स टू बी एग्जीक्यूटेड इन पैरेलल
यानी कि पैरेलल में जो मैक्सिमम नंबर ऑफ़
टेंपलेट्स ये एग्जीक्यूट कर सकता है वो
कितना कर सकता है तो आप न c के थ्रू दे
सकते हैं तो इसमें मेन जो है आपका हान आए
है जो रेट लिमिट है उसको कम कर दीजिएगा
ज्यादा डिटेक्शंस के कम चांसेस आपके कम
होंगे आपके जो फायर वल ब्लॉकिंग के चांसेस
है कम होंगे आपके रिक्वेस्ट के एंड आपके
रिक्वेस्ट जो है वो प्रॉपर्ली वहां तक
पहुंचेंगे होस्ट तक ठीक है ये काम करिएगा
उसके बाद ऑप्टिमाइजेशंस है तो टाइम आउट आप
करके ऑप्टिमाइज कर सकते हैं टाइम टू वेट
इन सेकंड बिफोर टाइम आउट तो डिफॉल्ट आपका
10 सेकंड है तो इसको आप रहने दे सकते हैं
आप 5 सेकंड भी कर सकते हैं वो आपके ऊपर है
तो टाइम आउट आप लगा सकते हैं
रिट्रांसमिट कई बार क्या होता है आता है
कि रिक्वेस्ट जो जाती है किसी एक होस्ट के
लिए तो फेल्ड हो जाती है कई बार तो आप यह
हाइन रिट्राईंग और नंबर ऑफ
रिट्रैक्टिंग आप दो दो या तीन या चार ऐसे
करके लगा सकते हैं याद रखिएगा जितने
ट्राइज को बढ़ाएंगे उतना जो है आपका जो
ड्यूरेशन है स्कैनिंग का वो थोड़ा बढ़
जाएगा ठीक है आई होप यू गेटिंग ओके तो
यहां पे कुछ ये सारी चीजें हैं यहां पे
उसके बाद आप यहां पे आएंगे तो देयर आर
हेडले मोड आल्सो अगर आप हेडले मोड में
जाना चाहते हैं इनेबल टेंप्लेट दैट
रिक्वायर हेडले ब्राउजर सपोर्ट ठीक है
हेडले ब्राउजर सपोर्ट के लिए ये जरूरी है
ठीक है अ लाइक अगर आप चलाना चाहे तो नहीं
तो कोई कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है आप सीधे जा
सकते
हैं यहां पे डी बग मोड है यहां पे वही डी
बग मोड आपको सारे रिक्वेस्ट रिस्पांस को
शो करने हैं तो डी बग मोड ऑन कर दीजिए
वर्वस मोड ऑन कर दीजिए जितने भी आउटपुट
वर्वस आउटपुट है सारे कुछ शो करेंगे अपडेट
वाली आपको बताई दिया सारी चीजें तो इस
तरीके से ये न्यूक्लि आपका वर्क करता है
चलिए अब यहां पे हम इसको इन एक्शन भी
देखेंगे बट उसके पहले हम यहां पे चलेंगे
न्यूक्लि के ऑफिशियल पेज
पे हां जी ऑफिशियल पेज पे यहां पे आएंगे
एंड यहां पे आने के बाद हम एक पहली एक
वल्नरेबल वेबसाइट को पहले हम पहले हम एक
वल्नरेबल वेबसाइट को सेटअप करेंगे वल
वल्नरेबल वेबसाइट जो है हमारी वर्डप्रेस
की वेबसाइट है उसको सेट अप कर लेते हैं
एंड दैट इज कॉल्ड डीवीडब्ल्यू प डैम
वल्नरेबल वर्डप्रेस सिंपल ये वाली गिट हब
रिपोजिटरी आपको यहां पे मिल जाएगी या
डीवीडब्ल्यू प आ डम वल्नरेबल वर्डप्रेस
वाली जो लिंक है इस पे जाइएगा 12700 3137
पोर्ट पे यह काम कर रहा होगा तो हम यहां
पे
फिलहाल चलते हैं यहां पे 9 31 377 पे आते
हैं तो यहां पे ये ऑलरेडी सेटअप है मेरा
इसलिए य डायरेक्टली ओपन हो चुका है आपको
सेटअप करना पड़ेगा तो आप पहले क्या करेंगे
मैं आपको बता देता हूं पहले यह कमांड
चलाएंगे गेट क्लोन फिर आप सीडी डायरेक्टरी
में जाएंगे फिर डॉकर कंपोज बिल्ड करेंगे
एंड बिल्ड करने के बाद आप डायरेक्टली आप
इस इंटरफेस पे आएंगे यहां पे आ के आप
वर्डप्रेस का यूजर नेम पासवर्ड सेट करेंगे
एंड उसके बाद आप यह वाला कमांड रन करेंगे
ठीक है नहीं तो यह कमांड जब आप रन करेंगे
तो डेटाबेस की एरर आएगी क्योंकि आपका
डेटाबेस सेट रहेगा नहीं तो इस वजह से आप
एनुअली कर नहीं रहे हैं तो इस वजह से ये
इशू आएगा तो उसके बाद आप यहां पे आप हमारी
एक डम वल्नरेबल वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट पे आ
चुके हैं जिस पे हम टेस्ट आउट कर सकते हैं
यह एक हमारा वेबसाइट है या वर्डप्रेस
वेबसाइट आप कह सकते हैं तो अब जो है हमारा
टारगेट जो है ये वाला हो सकता है हमारे
लिए अब देखो यहां पे क्या करना है मुझे
क्या करना है न्यू चलाना है हाइन य हमें
टारगेट दे देना है तो मैंने टारगेट सॉरी
मैंने टारगेट यहां पर मेंशन कर दिया यह
वाली हमारी टारगेट है लेबल वर्डप्रेस इसके
जगह पर आप रियल टारगेट यूज कीजिएगा
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल आप रियल टारगेट यूज
कीजिएगा कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है हां जी अब
यहां पर मैं एक और टैब ओपन कर लेता हूं
लेट्स
ओपन भैया क्या हुआ चलो एक और टैब य पर ओपन
कर लेता हूं मैं
न्यूक्लियर हाइफ एस दे देते हैं अब यहां
पे हम इसमें अलग-अलग ऑप्शंस को यूज करना
शुरू करते हैं न य हमने यूज कर लिया है
दैट्ची है हाइन एंटी यूज कर सकते हैं अगर
आपको न्यू टेंप्लेट यूज करने है बट हमें
न्यू टेंप्लेट यूज नहीं करने हमें नॉर्मल
टेंपलेट्स यूज करने है तो हाइन यहां पे t
दे देंगे अब हाइन t के थ्रू आप टेंप्लेट
की पूरी डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
चाहे तो या आप स्पेसिफिक टेंप्लेट को भी
यूज कर सकते हैं तो अब चलिए टेंप्लेट है
कहां पे उसमें चल लेते हैं राइट तो
टेंपलेट्स की लोकेशन आपको पता ही है लोकल
के अंदर न्यूक्लि टेंपलेट्स हैं न्यूक्लि
टेंपलेट्स के अंदर में आप आएंगे तो यहां
पे अलग-अलग टेंपलेट्स है तो मुझे एचटीटीपी
के अंदर के टेंपलेट्स यूज करने हैं और
एसटीटीपी में भी मान लो मुझे करने
हैं अ इसके अंदर मुझे कौन सी वले एबिलिटीज
के करने है वले एबिलिटीज में वर्डप्रेस है
क्या अ वर्डप्रेस वर्डप्रेस तो इसको यूज
करना है तो मैं क्या करूंगा मैं आपको बता
देता हूं मैं क्या करूंगा व्हाट आई विल डू
यहां पे स्ल रूट के अंदर में लोकल के अंदर
चलेंगे ठीक है न्यूक्लियर टेंपलेट्स के
अंदर चलेंगे इसके अंदर में एसटीटीपी के
अंदर में चलेंगे वनरे एबिलिटीज वाली
टेंप्लेट यूज करनी है और इसमें भी हमें
वर्डप्रेस वाली जो डायरेक्टरी वाली
टेंप्लेट है उसको यूज करनी है अब
वर्डप्रेस के डायरेक्टरी के अंदर में बहुत
सारे टेंपलेट्स यहां पे आपको देखने को मिल
जाएंगे ये सारे टेंप्लेट है वर्डप्रेस के
आप देखो यहां पे ये सारे वर्डप्रेस के
टेंपलेट्स इन सब को यूज करना है तो आप
सिंपली आप क्या कर सकते सकते हैं सिंपली
आप यह
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
लगाओ या फिर अगर आपको चाहिए कि एक
स्पेसिफिक सीवियरिंग के अकॉर्डिंग तो आप
हाइ फन एस लगा के सीवियरिंग के अकॉर्डिंग
दे सकते हैं फिलहाल तो मैंने यहां पे
नॉर्मल सा दिया अब यहां पे हाइ फन रेट
लिमिट लगाते हैं रेट लिमिट में 150 था हम
इसको कर देते 50 थोड़ा कम कर देते हैं
ताकि कोई डिटेक्शन किसी तरह का ना हो
हालांकि ये लोकल होस्ट पे है तो कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं आएगी बट स्टिल मैंने ये चीज
आपके लिए कर दिया ठीक है अब
देखिए क्या हुआ
भाई अंकित अंकित शमीम इनको एक बार रिमूव
कर दिया जाए अंकित को काफी ज्यादा ये
स्पैम कर रहे हैं इनको 24 आवर्स के लिए
हटाया जाए क्योंकि स्पैम वाले लोग पता आई
डोंट
लाइक नियमित आएगा भाई नियमित आएगा नियमित
आएगा जी अनियमित
आएगा सरय टेंप्लेट एक्चुअली में होते क्या
है चलो होते क्या है यह मैंने अभी बताया
था बट स्टिल मैं आपको एक बार रिपीट करता
हूं टेंप्लेट ठीक है रिपीट करता हूं
टेंप्लेट क्या होते हैं अगर आपको यह जानना
है टेंपलेट्स जो ये है न्यूक्लि आई के यह
एक सर्टेन वलने बिलिटी को फाइंड उनके
एक्सप्लोइट्स एक तरह का बोल सकते हैं वो
एक्सप्लोइट्स है उन लेबिलिटी के ये
टेंप्लेट के अंदर में मेंशन है अब जैसे यह
वर्डप्रेस के अवेलेबिलिटीज क्या है ठीक है
अब मान लो मेरे पास एक कोई भी टेंप्लेट
उठा लो एग्जांपल के लिए मैं दिखाता हूं
कोई भी टेंप्लेट दिखा लो 4043 या
प्लगइन एनालिटी फाई प्लगइन एक्सेसेस मान
लो ये एनालिटी फाई प्लगइन है कोई
वर्डप्रेस की उसकी एक्सेसेस की यह
टेंप्लेट है इसको मैं जूम इन करता
हूं अब देखो यहां पे क्या है एनालिटिका जो
भी आपकी प्लगइन की एक्सेसेस लेबिलिटी थी
उसका एक एक्सप्लोइट का ये टेंप्लेट है अब
क्या है
ये इस एलिट फाई एक प्लगइन है वर्डप्रेस की
जिसमें कि 4.2.1 जो प्लगइन वर्जन है उससे
लेस में जितने भी वर्जंस होंगे उसपे क्रॉस
सेट स्क्रिप्टिंग अवेलेबिलिटी थी तो एक
ऑथर है उन्होंने इसका टेंप्लेट डाला इनका
नाम है एकन
सीबोर मिस्टेक हो सकती है भाई नाम में तो
प्लीज इग्नोर सीरिटस की मीडियम तय हुई है
हमारी एंड यहां पे क्या है ये वर्डप्रेस
एनालिटी फाइड 4.2.1 डज नॉट स्केप द करंट
यूआरएल बिफोर आउटपुट इट बैक इन अ 404 पेज
व्हेन द 404 ट्रैकिंग फीचर इज इनेबल
लीडिंग टू रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग बस रेफरेंस यहां दिया हुआ है
इस पर्टिकुलर लेबिलिटी का सीवीएसएस यहां
पे दिया हुआ है यहां पे कौन सा सीवीएसएस
स्कोर यहां पे मैट्रिक्स जो है वो दिए गए
हैं सीवीएस स्कोर यहां पे 5.4 दिया गया है
मैट्रिक्स दिया गया गया है एंड सीडब्ल्यूई
आईडी यहां पे साइन जो है वो आपको यहां पे
मिल गई है ठीक है अब देखो यहां पे
वेरीफाइड है हां जी
वेरीफाइड है ठीक है उसके बाद यहां पे
google.it फाई ये
google2 एनालिटी फाई ये दिया गया है टैग्स
कौन-कौन से इसमें यूज़ किए गए हैं तो
डब्ल्यूपी अगर आप इन टैग्स का यूज करेंगे
तो ये टेंप्लेट ऑटोमेटिक यूज आ जाएगा जैसे
आपने क्या किया आपने कमांड क्या
डाला आपने कमांड अगर डाला होता यहां पे
आपने यह कमांड ना डाल के आपने अगर यह
कमांड डाला होता न्यूक्लि आई
हाइन यू यहां पर एस सॉरी एचटीटीपीएस डि
फोनिक्स ड कॉ यहां पर यह डाला होता और
हाइन टैग्स डाल के आपने इनमें से कोई भी
टैग यूज किया होता
ना यहां पर कोई भी टैग जैसे डब्ल्यूपी टैग
या वर्डप्रेस टैग या एनटी फाई टैग या
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन टैग या डब्ल्यूपी प्लगइन
टैग या एक्सेस टैग तो आप जैसे ही मान लो
कोई भी टैग मान लो टैग टैग्स यहां पर होता
और एक्सेसेस भी टैग यहां पे किया होता तो
यहां पे ये टैग देख लीजिएगा ये टैग ऑप्शंस
तो ये वाली जो पर्टिकुलर टेंप्लेट है
ऑटोमेटिक यूज में आ जाती इस टारगेट के
अगेंस्ट स्कैन करने के लिए ये समझ में आ
रहा है आप लोगों को जिस तरह से आप
न्यूक्लि को यूज करना चाहेंगे न्यूक्लि आई
को उस तरीके से आप टारगेट के अगेंस्ट यूज
कर सकते हैं ये मैं सिंगल टारगेट के ऊपर
बता रहा हूं आपके पास लिस्ट ऑफ टारगेट्स
है सब डोमस है डोमस है लाइव डोमस या लाइव
सब डोमेंस है उसको हाइ फनल के थ्रू यूज
करके सेम कमांड्स को आप रन करना है लाइव
टारगेट पे भी यह आपको समझ में आ रहा
है बताइए
मुझे एवरीवन
गेटिंग एवरीवन गेटिंग आर यू अंडरस्टैंडिंग
एवरीबॉडी प्लीज लेट मी नो प्लीज लेट मी नो
सभी लोग आपको समझ में आ रहा है इसके
वर्किंग समझ में आ रही है ना
बहुत कम लोग बोल रहे हैं या वर्किंग का
ऐसा क्यों बहुत कम लोग बोल रहे हैं
वर्किंग
का आ रिप्लाई बहुत कम लोगों का आ रहा है
ऐसा क्यों हो रहा है वई दिस हैपनिंग गाइस
इट शड नॉट हैपन लाक
दिस कंटिन्यू प्लीज नहीं मुझे अभी 50
रिप्लाई मिलेंगे तभी मैं कंटिन्यू
करूंगा नहीं यार मैं भी थोड़ी चीजों पर
स्टैंड बाय वो मोड में आ सकता हूं ऐसा
नहीं
है आप लोग
बताइए तब तक मैं पानी पी लेता
हूं पूरा समझ में आ रहा है क्या बात
है व्हाट इज द टॉपिक नेम एंड व्हाट आर यू
डूइंग यह तो अब आपकी आपकी आपके टेंशन
है लास्ट में आओगे तो ऐसे ही होगा शुरू से
रहा करो यार क्लास में तभी पता चलेगा ना
टॉपिक नेम क्या है क्या करा रहे हैं लास्ट
में आके पूछोगे टॉपिक
नेम आर एससीएसए कोर्स कब आएगा आएगा भाई
जल्दी आएगा आरएसीएस कोर्स आरएसएस पूरी मैं
करा दूंगा टेंशन नहीं लेना
है अरे स्पैम क्यों
करोगे हां राइट राइट राइट
ट ओके चलिए बांग्लादेश अच्छी बात है यहां
पे आपको टैग्स ये है अब यहां पे क्योंकि
एचटीटीपी वाली टेंप्लेट है तो आपको
एटीटीपी वाली जो टेंप्लेट है उसका जो
कीवर्ड है देन मेथड कौन सा गेट पाथ अब
देखो इसका पाथ क्या है ना पाथ यहां पे बेस
यूआरएल यानी जो आपका टारगेट आपका जो
टारगेट है उसका वो बेस यूआरएल यहां पे
रहेगा एंड उसके बाद यह पाथ है a404 बीब यह
पाथ हो गई आपकी यहां पे पर्टिकुलर एंड
उसपे यह स्क्रिप्ट जो है ये स्क्रिप्ट
आपका चलेगा तो ये पूरा का पूरा इस तरीके
से यहां पे पाथ मेंशन हो जाता है यहां पे
कुछ मैच कंडीशंस हैं मैच कंडीशंस में एंड
है एंड मैचस में टाइप पार्ट एंड वर्ड्स
टाइप में वर्ड्स है पार्ट में बॉडी है एंड
वर्ड्स कौन-कौन से भैया है कि टेक्स्ट या
जावास्क्रिप्ट तो ये अलर्ट एक्सेसेस
स्क्रिप्ट एंड यहां पे आपके डब्ल्यूपी
एनालिटी फाई ये आपके वर्ड्स हैं मैच
कंडीशंस में आते हैं आपके कंडीशंस आपका
एंड ही है यहां पे फिर टाइप में यहां पे
एंड मतलब कि जित और जितने जितने भी
कंडीशंस है सारे मैच कर रहे हैं सारे मैच
हो रहे हैं कंडीशंस में एंड यहां पे वर्ड
में यहां प टाइप फिर से वर्ड है पार्ट
यहां पे हेडर यहां पे वर्ड में है ये बॉडी
में जो वर्ड है उसके लिए था या हेडर में
जो वर्ड है उसके लिए था क्या है भैया हेडर
में क्या आना चाहिए टेक्स्ट या एसटीएम
मिलाने चाहिए जो आपका रिक्वेस्ट हेडर होता
है आपका उस तरीके से आपका हेडर में जो
रिस्पांस हेडर होते हैं उसमें जो आपके अ
वर्ड्स आते हैं उसके लिए यहां पे दिया हुआ
है टाइप स्टेटस में यहां पे 404 आना चाहिए
एंड देन इट्स डन तो इस तरीके से ये
टेंपलेट्स तैयार किए जाते हैं ये
टेंपलेट्स आपके होते हैं तो बेसिकली किसी
भी लेबिलिटी के एक्सप्लॉयड के लिए
टेंप्लेट है उसको एक्सप्लोइट कर करने के
लिए वो एक्सप्लोइट का फॉर्म है एंड आप
उसको न्यूक्लियर टेंप्लेट की तरह यूज कर
रहे हैं मास अ अटैक के लिए एक मास टारगेट
या एक सिंगल टारगेट के ऊपर में तो इस
तरीके से आप इसको रन कर सकते हैं
चलिए तो अब हम यहां पे इस पर्टिकुलर हमारे
होस्ट पे हमारे टारगेट पे हमने ये चीज डाल
दी हमने रेट लिमिट 50 कर दिया है यहां पे
बाकी ऑ आप देना चाहे बिल्कुल दे सकते हैं
आपकी मर्जी है नहीं देना चाहे आप छोड़
सकते हैं फिलहाल हम वर्डप्रेस के जितने
टेंप्लेट है सारे को यहां पर रन करने हैं
एंटर करेंगे यहां पे ये स्टार्ट होगा एंड
यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं कि टेंपलेट्स
लोडेड 179 यानी कि इसके अंदर 179 टेंप्लेट
होने चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से तो चलिए इसके
अंदर देख लेते हैं कितने हैं टेंपलेट्स है
टोटल 181 है 181 टेंप्लेट है इसके अंदर
टोटल और यहां पर लोड कितने हुए हैं
[संगीत]
179 यहां पर लोड हुए हैं यहां पे और कुछ
है टेंप्लेट क्लस्टर्ड फोर ठीक है यूजिंग
इंटरेस्ट ठीक है नो रिजल्ट्स फाउंड नो
रिजल्ट्स फाउंड यहां पे कोई रिजल्ट यहां
पे फाइंड नहीं हुआ है तो उसमें कोई टेंशन
नहीं है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है रिजल्ट अगर
नहीं फाइंड हुआ है तो उतना टेंशन आपको
नहीं लेना है तो हम और भी इसमें टेंपलेट्स
को यूज कर सकते हैं अब जैसे मान लो मैंने
यहां पे इस तरीके से किया अब मैं यहां पे
रेट लिमिट को यह वाली हटा देता
हूं आई होप कि हमारा यह वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट
चल रहा हो बिल्कुल चल रहा
है अब हम क्या करते हैं यहां पे यहां पे
हान s यहां पे हाइन s दे देते
हैं हाइन s देते हैं सीवियरिंग के
अकॉर्डिंग एंड यहां पे क्रिटिकल दे देते
हैं क्रिटिकल अब यहां पे हम एंटर करते हैं
अब हमने क्या किया यहां पे सीवियरिंग
क्रिटिकल रख दी हमारे सेम टारगेट पे एंड
अब हमने यहां पे स्टार्ट कर दिया हमारी
स्कैनिंग को 1080 टेंपलेट्स जो हैं यहां
पे आ चुके हैं क्रिटिकल सवेरिन यहां पे
हमारी स्कैनिंग जो है वो स्टार्ट हो चुकी
है है अब देखते हैं हमें रिजल्ट कुछ मिलता
है या नहीं मिलता है इस पर्टिकुलर टारगेट
के लिए लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग नो
रिजल्ट्स फाउंड यह हमने लोकेशन सही दिया
है क्या वो 3133 लोकेशन है ओके ओके 31 337
हमने यहां पे गलत लोकेशन दिया हुआ है
दैट्ची में भी कुछ मिला नहीं था तो यहां
पे 31 337 पोर्ट है वही मैं सोच रहा था कि
कुछ फाइंड क्यों नहीं हो रहा तो वपस वाले
में भी कुछ ना कुछ फाइंड करके आपको यह
देगा तो अभी देखते हैं हां जी फाइंड कर
रहा है ये तो हमने कुछ पोर्ट नंबर गलत दे
दिया था
दैट्ची की जिसमें कि इसको यूजर नेम एक
मिला है डेनिक्स ये अच्छी चीज है यहां पे
मिला हमें दैट्ची
ठीक है नॉर्मल सा एक्सएमएल आरपीसी इनेबल्ड
है चलिए अब इसको हम वैसे ही टैग वाली जो
हम देख रहे थे टैग वाली दे देते हैं भैया
भैया कहां गए 100 हां ये रहा रेट लिमिट को
हटा देते हैं लोकल होस्ट पे है तो इसकी
वैसे कोई नीड नहीं है अब यहां पे हान ए से
सिरिटी हान s एंड यहां पे हम डालते हैं
क्रिटिकल अब देखते हैं क्रिटिकल में क्या
दिक्कत है क्या आती है कौन-कौन सी
टेंपलेट्स कितने टेंप्लेट यूज हो रहे हैं
लगभग 1000 कुछ 1080 टेबलेट्स यूज हो रहे
हैं तो अभी देखो क्रिटिकल अगर कोई वने
एबिलिटीज इसको मिलती है जैसे सवी
2028 72 ये मिली है इसको तो ये क्रिटिकल
मेन वेबसाइट पे हमारी क्रिटिकल वनबिल है
तो अगर आपको इसके बारे में जानना है तो
सीवी 2028 7772 आप इसको सिंपल सा यहां पे
लाके एंड इसको सर्च आउट कर सकते हैं एंड
इसके बारे में जानकारी प्राप्त कर सकते
हैं तो यहां पे सीवी देख सकते हैं आप 202
8772 क्या है भैया ये तो यह कोई प्लगइन से
रिलेटेड अ यहां पे एक वलने बिलिटी है दिस
इज इनफा डब्ल्यूपी क्लाइंट प्लगइन बिफोर
1.9
9.45 फॉर वर्डप्रेस जज अ मिसिंग ऑथराइजेशन
चेक इन आई डब्ल्यूपी एमएम बी सेट
रिक्वेस्ट इन . पीएपी एनी अटैकर हु नोज द
यूजर नेम ऑफ एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर कैन लॉग इन ये
बहुत ही क्रिटिकल लेबिलिटी है कि सिर्फ
यूजर नेम पता है तो लॉगइन कर सकते थे इस
पर्टिकुलर क्लाइंट प्लग इन के थ्रू एक
वनबिल के थ्रू तो इस वजह से यह यहां पे
क्रिटिकल के उसमें यहां पे यहां पे इसको
दिया गया है और यहां पे आपको क्रिटिकल में
मिली है अब यहां
पे मान लो मुझे सारे ही टेंपलेट्स यूज
करने हैं तो मैं सारे ही टेंपलेट्स को यूज
कर सकता हूं कैसे यूज कर सकता हूं हान t
दिया मेरे को रूट में चलना है लोकल में
चलना है स्लैश लोकल में चलना है एंड
न्यूक्लि आई टेंप्लेट यूज करनी है अब मैं
न्यूक्लि आई टेंप्लेट सिर्फ ये डायरेक्टरी
मेंशन कर रहा हूं इसका मतलब इसके अंदर
जितने भी टेंपलेट्स है आप देखो ना यार
देखो यहां पे ये न्यूक्लि टेंपलेट्स है
न्यूक्लि टेंपलेट्स के अंदर सारे
टेंपलेट्स को ये यूज कर लेगा एंड हमें
रिजल्ट प्रोवाइड करेगा तो हम अगर यहां
एंटर करते हैं तो अभी आपको देखेंगे कि
कितने टेंपलेट्स को यहां पे ये अ बेसिकली
जो है अ लोड कर रहा है अभी हम देखेंगे हाउ
मेनी टेंपलेट्स तो 8506 टेंपलेट्स को इसने
लोड किया है यानी कि 8506 टेंपलेट्स को ये
रन कर रहा है पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के अगेंस्ट
में सारी टेंपलेट्स ये रन कर रहा है यानी
आप इस तरीके के भी काम कर रहे हैं वही है
कि इसमें थोड़ी इश्यूज ये आएंगे आपको कि
अगर आप जब रियल वेबसाइट पे करेंगे ना तो
उनके फायरवॉल डिटेक्शन सिस्टम्स जो
फायरवॉल्स हैं वो डिटेक्ट करेंगे आपके
रिक्वेस्ट को फ्लैग कर देंगे या फिर ब्लॉक
कर देंगे आपके रिक्वेस्ट को वहां पे आप
रेट लिमिटिंग वगैरह यूज कर सकते हैं
वीपीएस प ज्यादा बढ़िया रहेगा अगर आप यूज
करते हैं तो थोड़ी बहुत चेंजेज कर लीजिएगा
रिक्वेस्ट सेंड करने की आपकी प्रोसेस में
रिक्वेस्ट किस तरीके से सेंड कर रहे हैं
आप होस्ट को सर्वर होस्ट सर्वर किस तरीके
से रिक्वेस्ट एक्सेप्ट कर रहा है हैंडल कर
रहा है वो बहुत इंपोर्टेंट होता है ताकि
आपको सही से रिस्पांस मिल पाए यह बात याद
रखिएगा ठीक
है ओके नसिया हैं हंट करने में बिजी रहो
अच्छी बात है
लविंग दैट यू आर कंसिस्टेंटली विथ योर बग
हंटिंग ग्रेट लगे रहो जरूर सफलता तो बहुत
अच्छे से
मिलेगी सर आपकी वीडियोस देख देख के मैंने
00 डलर का बग मिला था एसकल क्या बात है
अंकित गेमिंग कांग्रेचुलेशन अंकित गेमिंग
या लिंकन पर भी डाला करो टैग क्या करो
फनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
को
या हा नेक्स्ट वीडियो प्रिविलेज पर वीडियो
आएंगी यार पहले जो तो मेरे अकॉर्डिंग जो
जो वीडियोस आ रही है उसको देखते जाओ प्लीज
प्रिविलेज एक्सशन के पीछे मत पढ़ा करो या
किसी भी टॉपिक के पीछे मत पढ़ा करो जैसे
जैसे मैं ला रहा हूं प्लीज आप उसके थ्रू
जाओ और आपको अभी पता है ना आप सबको शायद
पता नहीं कि हम एक डीसी जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल
की भी सीरीज स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं आप सबको
पता
है शॉर्ट्स में बताया था मैंने जो अभी
लास्ट शॉर्ट्स मैंने डाला हुआ था
एक हम सीरीज स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं एंड यह
जो सीरीज है इसमें इसके जो कंटेंट है
वह
मतलब बहुत ही रिनाउंड अ सर्टिफिकेशन
प्रैक्टिकल रिलेटेड एक सर्टिफिकेशन है
आपको पता ही होगा उसका ईजेपी एंड ओएसपी के
बहुत सारे टॉपिक्स यह कंबाइन करके हम यह
जो आपकी क्लास है वह फ्री में आपको कराने
वाले हैं मतलब एक ऐसी क्लास जो बेसिकली
करने के बाद आप ईज पीटी जैसे एग्जामिनेशन
इजली बिना किसी के बिना किसी पेड क्लासेस
या कोर्स के भी शायद क्रैक कर पाएंगे आपके
अंदर वो कैपेबिलिटीज थोड़ी होनी चाहिए हम
आपको पूरा गाइड करें वो ये सीरीज जो आने
वाली है बग बाउंट की चलते रहेगी साथ में
वो भी सीरीज चलेगी बट वो जो सीरीज होगी
गाइस वो सीरीज काफी लंबी सीरीज है छछ
महीने तक चल सकती है एंड बहुत सारी चीजें
उसमें आने वाली है इतने डीप टॉपिक्स हैं
बहुत कुछ है लाइक यू विल बी अमेज्ड आपको
ऐसा कंटेंट तो कहीं नहीं मिला होगा आज तक
पूरे साइबर सिक्योरिटी कम्युनिटी में
अ क्या
है ओके चलिए आई होप यू गट एवरी बडी
अंडरस्टैंड दिस राइट चलिए तो ये न्यूक्लि
न्यूक्लि ये हमें रिजल्ट मिल गया आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे 8506 टेंपलेट्स यूज हुए
हमारे टारगेट पे यहां पे एंड टारगेट पे
आपको यहां पे सीवी मिले हैं आपको 2020 20
877 221311 2021 का मिला है क्रिटिकल हाई
मीडियम आपको मिला है यहां पे मीडियम वनबिल
यहां पे फिर लो एक मिला आपको पाथ info.php
ये जो है ये आपकी बेसिकली लीक हो रही है
उसके बाद इफ इंफॉर्मेशन वनबिल यहां पे
मिली है जिसमें कि एचटीटीपी मिसिंग
सिक्योरिटी हेडर्स आ रही है टेक डिटेक्ट
में आपको यहां पे मिला है कुछ चीजें
वर्डप्रेस लॉगिन के अंदर में वर्डप्रेस
लॉगिन का पाथ मिला है एड माइनर पैनल आपको
मिला हुआ है देर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट यू
हैव गॉट हियर यूजर नेम आपको डे फोनिक्स
वाली जो चीज है वो आपको मिली हुई है लो के
अंदर में तो इस तरीके से अब आप यहां पे
लाइव जो वेबसाइट है वो भी आप चला सकते हैं
देखो इसका सबसे इसकी ब्यूटी क्या है मैं
आपको बता देता हूं व्हाट इज द ब्यूटी यहां
पे मैंने आपको यहां पे पहले ही बताया
था कि आप पर्टिकुलर इस न्यूक्लि आई को ना
दूसरे टूल्स के साथ भी चला सकते हैं जैसे
सब फाइंडर के साथ आपको चलानी है सब फाइंडर
यहां पे आपको टारगेट आपको देना है जो भी
टारगेट आपको देनी है वो टारगेट दे दीजिए
जैसे आप कोई भी टारगेट चूज कर लीजिए ठीक
है जैसे मैं आपको बता देता
हूं डेट्स को मैं डेट चलो शॉर्ट प्रमोटेड
में कर देते हैं स्टार्ट डेट करते हैं एंड
सेंडिंग में करते हैं अप्लाई करते हैं ठीक
है
ओके तो यहां पर फॉक्सी काट इसको देखते हैं
फक्सी काट को
लेट्स सी लेट फक्सी का कोई डोमेन बढ़िया
डोमेन है य प एडमिन एडमिन और ठीक है और
कोई डन है
क्या लेट्स गो टू द सम अदर
डोमेन इनडीड इड प ट्राई तो कर सकते हैं बट
इड यूज चलो इड के कोई दूसरे डोमेन प देखते
हैं कोई अदर डोमेन
प टा
[संगीत]
अब इसकी एक और पार्ट आएगी गाइस तो आपको
टेंशन नहीं लेना एक और पार्ट आएगी थोड़ी
एडवांस पार्ट होगी आपके लिए वो तो उसको
जरूर आप कीजिएगा तो यहां पर बहुत सार इसकी
इसके तो बहुत सारे टारगेट है ड क .
स इड fx.com इ fx.com क्या है
भाई fx.com
चलो इड flex.com ये टारगेट है इसको हम ले
लेते हैं तो आप इसको ना सब फाइंडर के साथ
देखो कैसे अब सब फाइंडर दो आप डोमेन जो
देना है वो दो एटीटीपी एक का यूज़ करो एंड
देन आप न्यूक्लि का यूज़ कर लो जस्ट सिंपल
पाइपलाइन के थ्रू आपको टारगेट्स चेंज करते
रहने है जैसे मतलब मैं क्या कर रहा हूं सब
फाइंडर सब फाइंडर इंस्टॉल होना चाहिए आपके
लिए हान डी दे दिया हमने यहां पे टारगेट
हमने यहां पे मेंशन कर दी हान यहां पे
साइलेंट कर दिया अ साइलेंट करके अब हम
यहां पे इसको एटीटीपी एक से पास करते हैं
काली में
http1 नाम से ये पैकेज है इसको और इसके जो
आउटपुट है इसको हम पास पास करेंगे
न्यूक्लि के अंदर में तो न्यूक्लि न t दे
देते हैं अब यहां पे इन्होंने क्या किया
है देखो मैं आपको बताता हूं इन्होंने यहां
पे क्या किया है कि टेक्नोलॉजी वाली ओनली
यहां पे अ यूज करी है टेक्नोलॉजी डिटेक्ट
करने के लिए जो भी अ इसका टेंप्लेट है वो
यूज किया है तो हम इसमें कोई भी टेंप्लेट
यूज कर सकते हैं अभी इसका ये किस चीज पे
बनी है अरे वाह क्या बात है ये वर्डप्रेस
के ऊपर बनी है इड flex.com तो ये काफी
बढ़िया हम इसमें वर्डप्रेस वाली जो जो चीज
है ना वो यूज कर लेते हैं तो हमने टाइ
दिया यहां पे रूट लोकल यहां देते हैं
न्यूक्लि टेंपलेट्स यहां देते हैं
एसटीडीपी के अंदर में आता है वर्डप्रेस
आता है वर्डप्रेस एटीपी के अंदर आता है ना
यार नहीं वनबिल के अंदर में आता है एंड
यहां पे आ जाता है वर्डप्रेस ठीक है ये दे
दिया हमने तो व्हाट विल हैपन लेट्स सी
क्या होता है ना मैं आपको अभी दिखा देता
हूं मैं अब यहां पे एंटर करूंगा एंड देखिए
क्या होता है यहां पे एंटर किया यहां पे
न्यूक्लि पे आ रहे हैं एटीटीपी एक हो चुका
आपका नाउ वी आर ऑन न्यूक्लि आई लेट्स
सी यहां पे आ रहा है कि 179 यहां पे किए
गए हैं यहां पे नो रिजल्ट्स फाउंड बेटर लक
नेक्स्ट टाइम कोई रिजल्ट यहां पे फाइंड
नहीं किए गए हैं बट कोई बात नहीं कोई
टेंशन नहीं है यहां पे आप अलग टैक्स का भी
मेंशन कर सकते हैं अगर आपको टैक्स देना है
तो न्यूक्लि आई हाइ फन एस दे दीजिए या
सवेरिन टैक्स दे दीजिए या हान ए दे दीजिए
हान एस दे दीजिए एंड इंफो करके हम देख
लेते हैं एक बार इंफो में कुछ आता है
क्या लेट्स सी इफ वी आर गेटिंग सम
इंफो इंफो में अगर कुछ आता है तो अ
थ्री 3801 तो कुछ ऐसा कुछ खास आया नहीं है
हमारे पास ऐसा कुछ तो आप इस तरीके से भी
इसको यूज कर सकते हैं लाइक कोई भी एक
डोमेन है आप उसके अगेंस्ट उसके सब डोमेन
वगैरह फाइंड करके वैसे आप जनरली अगर आप
इसको वैसे चलाएंगे ना देखो अगर आप इसको
वैसे सिर्फ चलाते हैं
अगर आप इसको इस तरीके से चलाते हैं ओनली
सब फाइंडर नडी करके एंड इड flex.com इस
तरीके से चलाते हैं अब देखिए तो यह क्या
करता है सब डोमस को इनमेट करता है ठीक है
इ flex.com के जितने भी सब डोमस है उसको
इनमेट करता है इसका काम यही होता है तो
यहां पे जीरो सब डोमस फाइंड हुए हैं इस
वजह से आपके यह इश्यूज आ रहे हैं अब हम
यहां पे क्या कर देते हैं सिंपल सा एक मेन
जो आपकी वेबसाइट है इसको ही उठा के ले
लेते हैं ठीक
है यहां पे ind.com को ले लेते हैं सो
लेट्स टेक
इड कॉ एस अ
टारगेट
हा तो यहां पर हम थोड़ा चेंज करते हैं अ
लिटिल बिट ऑफ चेंज एंड यहां पे कर देते
हैं इसको सी वेरि को हटा देते हैं
प्रीवियस वाले में चलते हैं वर्डप्रेस
वाली वटी में लेट्स गो टू ind.com
ठीक है नाउ लेट्स सी व्ट इज हैपनिंग
नो रि फाउंड ठीक
है रेटिंग सब डोमेन ठीक है जीरो सब डोमस
ओके आई थिंक यर वी नीड टू डी www.com
ओके ओ लेट्स डू वन
थिंग यहां से यह वाली एक बार इसको मेंशन
करते हैं
ट
क ठीक है एक बार आते हैं आते हैं आप आपके
पास भी आते हैं जस्ट वेट प्लीज जस्ट वेट
ठीक है तो यहां पर लेट्स सी व्ट इ हैपनिंग
आई थिंक सब सब फाइंडर इ आउटडेटेड टस वा इट
नॉट वर्किंग सब फाइंडर जो है इसकी वजह से
सब
फाइंडर एंड यहां
पे ओके सो सब फाइंडर को थोड़ा अपडेट करके
देखते हैं हान हान यूपी अपडेट करके देखते
हैं इसको लेट अपडेट फाइंडर क्योंकि यह
पुराना वर्जन था इस वजह से शायद कुछ इशू आ
रहे होंगे तो अब जो है अब एक बार देखते
हैं डीड कॉ ना लेटस सी अपडेट हमने सब
फाइंडर को अपडेट किया है जीरो सब डोमेन वई
इट इ लाइक दिस ग हा फंडी
google.com लेट स फंडर google.com
ओके सो रेटिंग तो यहां पर रेट हो गई है सब
डोमस 5879 तो यहां पर कुछ इशू है मैं
google.com भी कर देता हूं एक बार इसको
देख लेते हैं हा जी तो दिस इ गेटिंग
एक्स यहां पर यह हो रहा है तो अभी हम इसको
इनडीड के मेन क प कर लेते प लेी ओके
ओके देर आर सम इश्यूज विद दिस एंड व्ट इज
द
इशू कैन नॉट यूज द बफर ओवर सोर्स बिकॉज
देर वाज नो एपीआई ओके एपीआई इशू एपीआई इशू
ओके ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है सो दिस इज लेट्स
चेंज द टारगेट यहां पे एक टारगेट को हम
इशू करते हैं य प चेंज हम करते हैं टारगेट
को टारगेट में हम यहां प इशू करते हैं
canva.com
कवा कॉ टारगेट आ टारगेट इज कवा कॉ सो
लेट्स
अ गिव यर canva.com यहां पे अब हमारा
टारगेट चेंज हो रहा है एंड वी विल सेम
कमांड व विल यूज सेम कमांड यहां पे बस ये
जो टेंपलेट्स हैं ये वले एबिलिटीज वाली
टेंपलेट्स ओनली रखने देते हैं वर्डप्रेस
मेंशन नहीं करते हैं एंड यहां पे हम हमारा
जो टारगेट है वह चेंज करते हैं कैनवा पे
एंड लेट्स ट्राई ऑन दिस कैनवा लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज हैपनिंग कें सा फाइंड अ वर्जन
ठीक है नो रिजल्ट फाउंड कुछ ऐसा नहीं हुआ
है तो मतलब कहने का मतलब है
कि एक बार एक बार ठीक है एक बार यह वाली
भी रिमूव कर लेते हैं राइट राइट राइट हम
प्रोटोकॉल रिमूव कर लेते हैं एटीटीपी वाली
जो प्रोटोकॉल है उसको रिमूव कर देते हैं
सो लेट्स रिमूव दिस एटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल एंड
ड कवा कॉ ठीक है हा नो नो नो नो नो नो
लेट्स डू वन
थिंग लेट्स डू कै ind.com
हम हम हम आप कोई सा भी टारगेट पे स्कैन कर
सकते हैं वो आपके ऊपर है टारगेट कोई सा भी
आप चूज कर लीजिए दैट इज टोटली अप टू यू
ठीक है एंड उस पे आप इसको डायरेक्टली रन
कर सकते हैं सब फाइंडर से सब डोमस फाइंड
करके या तो आप एक वन बाय वन भी कर सकते
हैं अगर आपको मान लो कोई इश्यूज आ रहे हैं
तो आप वन बाय वन क्या करोगे सब फाइंडर से
सारे सब डोमेंस को फाइंड कर लोगे एचटीटीपी
एक से आप उनको लाइव चेक कर लोगे लाइव या
जो भी आपका मैचिंग कोड है 200 स्टेटस कोड
वाले चाहिए आपको तो वो आप निकाल लोगे सारे
सब डोमेंस जो भी 200 स्टेटस कोड यानी कि
जो वर्किंग है करेंटली उसके बाद न्यूक्लि
आप उस पर्टिकुलर लिस्ट ऑफ टारगेट पे
न्यूक्लि रन कर दो चला दो एंड बस कहानी
समाप्त तो यहां पे अभी कुछ टाइम ले रहा है
आई थिंक इट्स
वर्किंग या इट्स
वर्किंग तो यहां पे टेंपलेट्स लोड जो हुए
हैं वने एबिलिटीज के 890 890 टेंप्लेट वने
एबिलिटीज के लोड हुए हैं फाइनली इट्स
वर्किंग यहां पे हम एचटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल
मेंशन कर रहे थे उसे हमने हटा दिया है वो
दैट्ची
अ ठीक
है तो नाउ इट इज वर्किंग एंड यहां पे
क्लस्टर्ड है यहां पे
13 3710 रिक्वेस्ट को इसने रिड्यूस कर
दिया है भैया समझ में आ रहा है यह है
क्लस्टर्ड का
पावर नाउ इट इज वर्किंग एंड इट विल ट्राई
टू गिव यू समथिंग अगर वनबिल के अंदर कोई
भी टेंप्लेट काम कर रही है इस पर्टिकुलर अ
उस पे तो आपको मिल जाएगी तो आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे स्किप कैंडिडेट रप
क अनरिस्पांसिव 31 टाइम्स अनरिस्पांसिव 30
टाइम्स 30 टाइम्स 30 टाइम्स यह सारे
अनरिस्पांसिव है टारगेट्स इसलिए स्किप कर
दे रहे हैं और कोई बात नहीं है जो जो
टारगेट को स्किप नहीं होगा जो टारगेट काम
कर रहा है सक्सेसफुल होगा वह आपको वहां पे
उसके रिगार्डिंग जो भी रिजल्ट्स है वो
आपको देंगे अब यहां पे आप इसके और ऑप्शन
यूज कर सकते थे जैसे कि रेट लिमिट आप यूज
कर सकते थे रेट लिमिट वाली कम कर देते आप
वहां पे दूसरी चीज आप क्या कर सकते हैं कि
आप
इसमें डिटेक्शन को कम बनाने के डिटेक्शन
कम बनाइए इस इसका आपको ट्राई करना है
डिटेक्शन कम हो बस इसका आपको ट्राई करना
है ठीक है जितने कम डिटेक्शन हो उतने बेटर
होंगे आपके
लिए व्ट इ हैपनिंग डिबल
गाइस गा लाइव चल रहा है
आपका आई डोंट नो इ देर सम
इशू लाइव ऑन गोइंग लाइव में कोई इशू आ रही
है
क्या वीडियो भी वीडियो नहीं है
क्या वीडियो तो चल रही है शायद मेरे ख्याल
से ओ लेट मी सी इफ आई कैन एक्सेस द
इंटरनेट या इंटरनेट का इशू ओके आई थिंक
देयर इज सम नेटवर्क इशू अ
माइट ब सम नेटवर्क इशू आई
थिंक नहीं य नेटवर्क नेटवर्क काम नहीं कर
रहा ब यहां पर
यह इतने सारे स्किप सारे स्किप हो रहे हैं
तो आई थिंक नेटवर्क इशू है कुछ या मुझे लग
रहा था नेटवर्क इ होगा
शद ओके लेट मी सी देर सम इ
जी ओजी के
[संगीत]
एन अरे भैया वेरिफिकेशन कोड में क्या
दिक्कत
है जीओ क है क्या
यह एडमिन यहां डालते
हैं क के एन
तो आई थिंक देर वास सम नेटवर्क इशू बट अभी
भी नेटवर्क इशू है क्या
यार टारगेट से कंप्लीट लाइव क्लियर है ना
बट यहां पर चल नहीं रही है आई थिंक कुछ तो
प्रॉब्लम है शायद मे
बी यहां सिस्टम पर यह काम नहीं कर रहा
लेटस स्टॉप दिस थिंग लेट्स स्टॉप इट इसको
स्टॉप करके फिर देखते हैं कुछ इशू अगर आ
रहे हैं
तो ओके ओके दे सम नेट कंजेस ओके सो दिस
वाज ड्यू टू नेटवर्क कंजेशन ये नेटवर्क
कंजेशन के कारण था गाइज और कुछ भी नहीं था
दिस वाज जस्ट नेटवर्क कंजेशन नाउ आई थिंक
इट्स टोटली फाइन
नाउ या या लोड इंक्रीज के कारण नेटवर्क
कंजेशन हुआ था आपके मतलब हमारे यहां पे इस
वजह से ये चीज हुई है बट ये चीज दिस इज
नॉट गुड दिस इज नॉट गुड आई हैव टू चेंज द
ब्रॉडबैंड कनेक्टिविटी एक यहां पे एक लोकल
ब्रॉडबैंड मे को यूज करना पड़ा है बट आई
थिंक आई हैव टू स्विच टू j फ j f में ये
चीज नहीं है लोकल इसमें यही प्रॉब्लम है
इनको कुछ आता पता नहीं होता है यह बस
स्पीड दिखाते हैं कि हां इतने एबीपी अभी
हमने जो प्लान ले रखा है मैंने पता है कौन
से प्लान ले रखा है ब्रॉडबैंड का 200
एबीपीएस के आसपास का ब्रॉडबैंड का प्लान
है और ये जब fast.com पे आप आओगे ना तो ये
250 300 जो स्टार्टिंग में भी जो दिखा रहे
हैं ना वो गलत है दैट इज अ रंग परसेप्शन
रंग चीज है ये यहां पे 200 से ऊपर तो पहली
बात जानी नहीं चाहिए फ्लकचुएशंस होती है
जो कि नहीं होनी चाहिए जनरली नेट के केसेस
में बट यहां पे हो रहे हैं मन इट्स नॉट अ
गुड ऑप्शन गुड इंटरनेट कनेक्टिविटी तो
मुझे चेंज करना पड़ेगा ये ब्रॉडबैंड तो
अभी 200 एबीपीएस का प्लान मैंने ले रखा है
बट आई हैव टू स्विच टू j f 200 एबीपीए ये
लोकल था
ये ठीक है चलिए तो यह तो आपने देखा यहां
पे काफी सारी अ स्कैनिंग आपकी चलते चल
चलने लगी थी यहां पे तो ये नेटवर्क इस
तरीके से इसके टेंपलेट्स को आप यूज करते
हैं ठीक है जो भी आपके टेंपलेट्स हैं अब
अब आपके न्यूक्लि के अंदर ना अलग-अलग
टेंपलेट्स हैं जैसे मैंने आपको पहले ही
बताया कि न्यूक्लियर टेंपलेट्स में क्लाउड
के अलग है कोड के अलग है डीएसटी अलग है
डीएनएस अलग है फाइल के अलग है हैडलेस अलग
हेल्पर एटीटीपी के अलग है एटीटीपी में
बहुत सारे हैं फाइल्स के ऊपर जाएंगे तो
फाइल्स में भी बहुत सारे ए के हैं ऑट के
हैं बैश के हैं इलेक्ट्रॉन जेएस कीज लॉगस
मैलवेयर नट जस पल पीएचपी
python3 में बहुत सारे पे लोट्स हैं यानी
कि आपके टेंपलेट्स हैं जिसको आप यूज़ कर
सकते हैं टारगेट के अगेंस्ट में ठीक है तो
यहां पे मिस ओसेंट के रि रिगार्डिंग जो है
फिशिंग एंड यूजर न्यूमरेशन के रिगार्डिंग
भी आपको पेलेट्स यहां पे मिलेंगे तो अगर
आप ओसन के लवर हैं तो आप इसको यूज कर सकते
हैं टेकओवर्स में आप यूज कर सकते हैं
टेकओवर्स में वही आप सब डोमन टेकओवर भी है
देयर आर मल्टीपल सर्विसेस जो टेकओवर्स हैं
वो टेकओवर सर्विसेस का आप यूज कर सकते हैं
एडब्ल्यूएल टेकओवर है बिट बकेट है ठीक है
कैंपेन मनि कैंपेन मॉनिटर का है एवरीथिंग
इज इंक्लूडेड ठीक है इंटरकॉम हफ स्पॉट सब
कुछ यहां पे आपका इंक्लूड किया गया है ठीक
है तो आप यह सारे यूज कर सकते हैं अब ये
मुझे यह बताइए कि आप खुद से एक टारगेट चूज
करेंगे बक क्राउड के ऊपर में ठीक है या
किसी भी टारगेट के ऊपर जरूरी नहीं है बकड
के ऊपर आप यूज करें आप किसी भी बग बाउंट
प्लेटफॉर्म के ऊपर टारगेट चूज कर सकते हैं
मैनुअली चूज कर सकते हैं ग डॉक का यूज
करके कर सकते हैं डायरेक्ट अप्रोच कर सकते
हैं आप एक टारगेट लेंगे उसकी सब डोमेंस को
फाइंड करेंगे आपका क्या है ना मैं आपको
बता देता हूं यहां
प चूज अ
टारगेट फाइंड
ऑल
द पॉसिबल लाइव सब डोमेन एंड डोमस डोमस का
मतलब वर्टिकल एंड रिजनल दोनों की बात में
कर रहा हूं
ठीक
रन रन
स्पेसिफिक न्यूक्लि टेंपलेट्स अगेंस्ट
दोज टारगेट्स विथ प्रॉपर रेट लिमिट
एंड
ऑप्टिमाइजेशन इसके साथ आप उसमें रन करेंगे
ट्राई टू
फाइंड वल्नरेबल
इन देम एंड उसमें आप वनबिल फाइंड करने की
कोशिश करेंगे ठीक है ये एक छोटा सा टास्क
है जो आपको करके लाना है नेक्स्ट क्लास के
पहले नेक्स्ट क्लास थोड़ा ए हो जाएगा इस
वजह से आप इसको जरूर कर लीजिएगा न्यूक्लि
का ही क्लास होगा और भी इंटरेस्टिंग आपकी
नेक्स्ट क्लास होने वाली है तो उसको जरूर
इस चीज को आप करके आइएगा आई होप इतना बता
दीजिए कि न्यूक्लिया यूज तो आप कर पाएंगे
ना आज की क्लास के बाद से मतलब टारगेट के
अगेंस्ट आप यूज तो कर पाएंगे इसका अलग-अलग
ऑप्शंस जो है उसको आप एक्सप्लोर करते हुए
यूज तो कर पाएंगे ना इतना तो आपको सीखने
को मिल ही गया होगा अभी आज की क्लास में
राइट कर लेंगे आप लोग एवरीवन कैन डू बता
दीजिए बता दीजिए प्लीज
एवरीवन कैन
डू ठीक है ठीक
है ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट सारे टेंप्लेट सारे
ऑप्शंस को आप यूज कीजिएगा यहां पे न्यू
टेंपलेट्स के लिए बस एंटी यूज कर लीगा जो
भी लेटेस्ट रिलीज में ऐड हुए तो बस वही
आपके ऐड होंगे फिल्टरिंग ऑप्शंस को यूज
कीजिएगा टैग्स टैग्स वगैरह का यूज कर सकते
हैं आप जैसे मैंने आपको बताया टैग्स के
थ्रू करना है सीवियरिंग करना है जो भी
आपको करना है तो आप यूज कर लीजिएगा ठीक है
यह सारे तो कोशिश आप यही रहनी चाहिए सिंपल
सा कि आपका टारगेट है उसकी जितनी सब
डोमेंस फाइंड करना है फाइंड कीजिए सबके
अगेंस्ट न्यूक्लि आई को चलाइए और ज्यादा
अगर आप क्लाउड या वीपीएस में चला रहे हैं
तो ज्यादा बेटर है ज्यादा जल्दी रिजल्ट्स
आएंगे जल्दी आपको जो है रिजल्ट आपको मिलके
आ जाएगा ठीक
है नेक्स्ट बक बाउटी की क्लास बहुत जल्द
होगी टेंशन नहीं लेना आपको बस इतना ही
कंप्लीट कीजिए आप अपने दोस्तों के बीच
वीडियोस को शेयर कीजिए अगर आपको अच्छी
लगती है वीडियोस क्लासेस हेल्पफुल लग रही
है तो एंड डीसी जीएसपी प्रैक्टिकल का वेट
कीजिए मैं आपको किस बारे में बात कर रहा
हूं वी आ
मैं इस पर इस पर लिखता हूं ज्यादा अच्छा
लगेगा फिगलेट है कि नहीं
भाई क्या बात है इंस्टॉल है फिगलेट
वी आर लंचिंग डीसी जेएसपी
प्रैक्टिकल तो डीसी जसपी प्रैक्टिकल हम लच
करेंगे बहुत जल्द बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है
मैंने आपको पहले ही बोला है कि आपने
इमेजिन नहीं करा है वह कंटेंट आपको उसके
अंदर मिलेगा बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट पेड
ट्रेनिंग जो आपको देते हैं ना पेड कोर्सेस
आप खरीदते हैं उसमें भी उसका 10 पर भी
नहीं मिलता होगा आपको उस तरह का कंटेंट
आपको उसमें मिलेगा मतलब आपका दिमाग हिल ना
जाए साइबर सिक्योरिटी में जो इंटरेस्टेड
है जो पागल है साइबर सिक्योरिटी के लिए
बहुत पैशनेट है मेरी तरह साइबर सिक्योरिटी
ही सिर्फ उनको दिखते है उनको सिर्फ इसी
डोमेन में मजा आता है उनके लिए यह काफी ट
होने वाला है ट्स इट चाहे वो आप एक
एंटरप्रेन्योरशिप माइंड के हो चाहे आप एक
जॉब माइंडसेट के हो बिजनेस माइंडसेट जो भी
व्हाट एवर जॉब आप करियर देख रहे हो कुछ भी
आपके लिए स्कूल स्टूडेंट्स हो कॉलेज हो
सबके लिए बेनिफिशियल रहेगा ठीक है
ओके चलिए तो वीपीटी डिफरेंट रहेगा डीसीएस
प्रैक्टिकल डिफरेंट रहेगा आपका दोनों में
डिफरेंस रहेगा ठीक है दोनों सिलेबस बीडीसी
जस भी प्रैक्टिकल सिलेबस अभी जब हम
बताएंगे तो आपको समझ में आ जाएगा कि क्या
डिफरेंस है एगजैक्टली ठीक है तो चलिए आज
के सेशन के लिए बस इतना ही रखते हैं एंड
यहां पे बस आपको सिंपली क्या करना है लाइक
कर देना है वीडियो को शेयर कर देना है
आपको अपने दोस्तों के बीच में एंड
सब्सक्राइब कर देना है हमारे चैनल को
दैट्ची
है लाइक
शेयर क्या कर रहे हैं भाई ये ऑप्शन
लाइक करना है शेयर करना है एंड सब्सक्राइब
करना है फिगलेट ऑ फिगलेट फिगलेट ठीक है
लाइक शेयर एंड सब्सक्राइब ट्स इट ठीक है
चलिए इतना कर लीजिए मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
क्लास में बहुत जल्द एंड बहुत-बहुत
धन्यवाद आप लोग आए जुड़े यहां पे ऐसे ही
इतने ही नंबर्स में अगर आप आते रहेंगे एंड
अपनी एनर्जी को इसी तरीके से कंटिन्यू
करेंगे तो मुझे भी काफी मजा आएगा आपको
यहां पे सिखाने में एंड और भी क्लासेस
फ्रीक्वेंसी जाएंगी थैंक यू सो मच
एवरीबॉडी ज हम मिलेंगे एक डाउट सेशन के
साथ यानी कि आपके डाउट्स जो भी होंगे डाउट
जो होते हैं वो डाउट्स मैं लूंगा एंड आपके
डाउट्स को क्लियर करूंगा एक स्पेसिफिक
डाउट सेशन लूंगा उसमें स्पेसिफिक जो भी
आपके डाउट्स होंगे सबकी लिस्ट बनाते जाइए
अभी से उन डाउट सेशन में आप पूछ लीजिएगा
ठीक है आज की क्लास के लिए बस इतना ही
करते हैं काफी टाइम बाद मैं बोल रहा हूं
बेसिकली तो गला अभी अभी काम नहीं कर रहा
है ठीक है तो मिलते हैं तब तक के लिए टाटा
बाय बाय गुड नाइट एंड टेक केयर एवरी बडी
एंजॉय बाय